واهلا بكم مشاهدينا في حصاد الليله وفي
الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث وتتفاعل
اخرى البدايه من قطاع غزه وهذه الصور
المباشره عقب الاعلان عن اتفاق لوقف اطلاق
النار بين الفصائل الفلسطينيه والاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في غزه
[موسيقى]
الى مدن الجنوبيه تل ابيب حيث دوت صفارته
الانذار قبل ساعه واحده من دخول اتفاق وقف
اطلاق النار حيز التنفيذ
والى تركيا وتحديدا في اسطنبول ويستعد
الاتراك باصواتهم في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والتشريعيه المقرره يوم غد الاحد
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
بعد خمسه ايام من تصعيد اسرائيلي في غزه
واستهداف في مواقع وقيادات الجهاد
الاسلامي ورد تصاعدي من غرفه عمليات
المقاومه في الداخل الاسرائيلي اتفاق
لوقفه اطلاق النار في قطاع غزه يدخل حيز
التنفيذ يتضمن وقف قتل المدنيين والافراد
وتدمير المنازل
وقياديهم بالجهاد يقول للجزيره انه تم
اطلاع كافه الفصائل على تفاصيله وان
الضمانات هي في وحده المقاومه
في تركيا وعشيه انتخابات رئاسيه وبرلمانيه
مصيريه صمت انتخابي وتاهب امني يسبق توجه
اكثر من 60 مليون ناخب الى صناديق
الاقتراع منافسه محتدمه بين التحالف
الجمهور الحاكم وتحالف الشعب المعارض
والمؤشرات تمنح المرشحين فرصا متساويه
بالتزامن مع اشتباكات باسلحه ثقيله في
الخرطوم بحري ومدرمان مصادر سودانيه تكشف
للجزيره عن بدء مفاوضات جديده بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع غدا الاحد في
جده بواسطه امريكيه سعوديه لتثبيت الهدنه
واخلاء المنشات الصحيه من المقاتلين وفتح
ممرات امنه تمهيدا لوقف دائم لاطلاق النار
قبل الحصاد نقاش معكم على منصات الرقميه
اعلان وقف اطلاق النار بين الجانبين
الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي ما هي مالات الاوضاع
عن الاعلان بعد الاعلان عن وقف اطلاق
النار في غزه وجاءت الاجابات على النحو
التالي ثمانيه وعشرون بالمئه توقعوا ايصمد
الاتفاق بينما راى مالي وسبعون بالمئه انه
ستعقبه
تصعيدات في الضفه الغربيه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصه الرقميه
ويمكنكم دخول صفحات التصويت عبر مسح رمز
الكيو ار الظاهره على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وهذه صور مباشره نشاهدها الان من غزه بعد
دخوله وقف اطلاق النار حيز التنفيذ
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اذا يخيم الهدوء الحذر على الاجواء في
قطاع غزه بعد ساعه من دخولي اتفاق وقف
اطلاق النار حيز التنفيذ بين الجانبين
الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي وقد تم اطلاقه
دفعات صواريخ من القطاع قبلت برد اسرائيلي
بعد الدقائق من موعد بدء تنفيذ الاتفاق
وقد انهى هذا الاتفاق تصعيدا الاسرائيليا
استمر خمسه ايام وبدا باغتيال عدد من
قيادي الجهاد الاسلامي واستهداف مواقعه
ومنشات ومبان في قطاع غزه وقد ردت فصائل
المقاومه بشكل المنسق ضمن ما يعرف بغرفه
عمليات المقاومه وكانت الاحداث قد تسارعت
مساء اليوم بعد الاعلان عن تقديم الوسطاء
صيغه جديده للاتفاق بين الجانبين تتضمن
وقف استهداف المدنيين وهدم المنازل
واستهداف الافراد وذلك حاله دخول وقف
اطلاق النار حيز التنفيذ
وفي الوقت نفسه قال رئيس الدائره السياسيه
في حركه الجهاد الاسلاميه محمد الهندي في
مقابله مع الجزيره ان الحركه ابلغت جميع
الفصائل الفلسطينيه
المنضويه تحت لواء غرفه العمليات المشتركه
بتفاصيل اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار
نحن ابلغنا الغرفه المشتركه والفضائل بهذا
الامور يعني ابلاغ مسبق لقبل الاعلان وكان
هناك موافقه
للتوصل الى هذا الاعلان الكل الكل تم
ابلاغهم في الغرفه المشتركه حماس في
البدايه وايضا
الفصائل المشاركه في الغرفه المشتركه
كما قال الرئيس الدائره السياسيه في حركه
الجهاد الاسلاميه ان الضمانات الحقيقيه
تبقى قوه ووحده الداخل الفلسطيني
والالتفاف حول خيار المقاومه
اسرائيل دائما
ان تتفلت ولا مهما كانت الضمانات وغير
الضمانات الضمانات هي قوتنا وحدتنا والان
احنا حافظنا على قوتنا وعلى وحدتنا الى
اخر لحظه
وطالما هناك
يعني وحده داخليه فلسطينيه والكفاف على
خيار المقاومه وطالما ان المقاومه تراكم
قوتها هذه الضمانه الوحيده امامنا ونحن
نتوقع كما حدث في السابق كما تقول نتوقع
عند اسرائيل ممكن ان ياتي يعني لحظات
وتدير ظهرها لاي اتفاق لكن على كل حال هذا
الاعلان ايضا هو اعلان مصري في الاساس
وبذل جهد كبير فيه
وموجود الان امام الجميع
وايضا من غزه مراسله الجزيره هشام زقوت
وتنضم الينا من تل ابيب مراسله الجزيره
نجوان السمري ومن جنوب عسقلان مراسل
الجزيره الياس كرم ونبدا بك هشام زقوط من
غزه والاجواء الان بعد ساعه من دخول
الهدنه حيز التنفيذ
يعني خرجت الناس الى الشوارع الجماهير
الفلسطينيه بمختلف عناصرها وفصائلها
ومواطنيها ومدنيها خرجوا الى هذا المفترقه
الرئيسي وهو مفترق السرايا وسط مدينه غزه
ورفعوا الاعلام اعلام الفصائل والاعلام
الفلسطينيه واطلقوا الالعاب الناريه
هلللوا وكبروا
بانتهاء فرحا بانتهاء هذا التصعيد بدايه
ومع دخول
وقت اطلاق النار حيز
التنفيذه كان نشطه في الشوارع سيارات
الناس بمختلف اعمارهم خرجوا الى هذه
الشوارع فرحا بهذا الوقت لاطلاق النار
وايضا فرحا بوحده المقاومه الفلسطينيه
التي يعني ردت العدوان الاسرائيلي
واطلقت الصواريخ وايضا
فوضت في القاهره
واصرت على ان يكون وقف اطلاق وقف
الاغتيالات جزءا اساسيا من هذا الاتفاق
والاهم بالنسبه لهم ايضا هو وقت
استهداف المنازل منازل المواطنين
والمدنيين وقبل قليل كان هناك ايضا مسير
لسيارات الاسعاف ولتيارات الدفاع المدني
التي مازال بعضها يتواجد هنا ويعتليه بعض
المواطنين فرحا ويرقصون ويتراقصون على هذه
السيارات فرحا
فرحا بهذا الوقت لاطلاق النار كما ترى زين
العابدين فان الجماهير تخرج والحياه بدات
تعود تدريجيا الى هذه الشوارع بعد ان
توقفت الحياه بشكل شبه كامل على مدار خمسه
ايام جراء هذا التصعيد الذي كان على قطاع
غزه وبدا واستمر لخمسه ايام اطلقت فيها
المقاومه العديد من الصواريخ وقصفت فيه
اسرائيل العديد من المنازل والعراضي
الزراعيه وكان هناك مؤتمر صحفي لاياد
البوزم المتحدث
وزاره الداخليه الفلسطينيه والذي شكر فيه
الجماهير واكد انهم وقفوا الى جانب
الجماهير الفلسطينيه هنا في غزه وايضا
تحدث عن
المهمات والتي قام بها قامت بها وزاره
الداخليه وايضا الوزاره الصحه وقال ان
هؤلاء الرجال سطروا ايضا وفي مقدماتهم
الدفاع المدني والخدمات الطبيه والشرطه
صدروا صورا جديده من البطوله والتضحيه من
خلال قيامهم بواجبهم اتجاه الشعب
الفلسطيني في ظل العدوان وايضا دعموا
واسندوا المواطنون المواطنين وحفظوا
استقرار الجبهه الداخليه واكد ان وزاره
الداخليه بدات بتطبيق خطه اعاده انتشار في
جميع محافظات القطاع فور الاعلان عن
انتهاء هذا العدوان لتقديم الخدمه اذا
المواطنون الان هنا هم يتجمهرون
ويؤكدون ان المقاومه استطاعت اجبار
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على
الرضوخ لمواقفها ولشروطها
طبعا هشام زقوطي انا صوره تتحدث عن نفسها
هذا المشهد
يجافي تماما المشهد طيله الايام الخمسه
الماضيه حيث كانت دائما الصوره خلفكم
الصمت المحلات مغلقه صور القصف هذا مشهد
مختلف لكن كيف هو المشهد في الجانب الاخر
نتحول الى نجوان سمري وهنالك ايضا الان
تصريح لديوان بنيامين نتنياهو ربما يكون
اول تصريح بعد دخول هذه الهدنه حيز
التنفيذ وهو اننا ملتزمون بالهدوء مقابل
الهدوء اذا تعرضنا الاعتداء او تهديد
سنفعل ما يلزم لحمايه انفسنا لكن ماذا عن
الاجواء بعد ساعه من دخول وقفه اطلاق
النار حيز التنفيذ
نعم هذا البي المقتضب صدر قبل قليل عن
ديوان رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو بلسان مستشار الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي الساحل نجبي بان اسرائيل عمليا
وافقت على الهدوء مقابل الهدوء وان كل
اعتداء او كل هجوم او تهديد ضد اسرائيل
سيقابل برد وهذا تماما ربما البيان الذي
تريده الحكومه الاسرائيليه ان يصدر في هذه
المرحله وكما ذكرنا سابقا اسرائيل تتجنب
في مثل هذه المواقف اصدار اي بيانات رسميه
تتحدث عن اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار ومنذ يوم
امس كانت هناك اشارات بان الحكومه
الاسرائيليه او نتنياهو يبحث عن صيغه
معينه فقط
للاعلان عن وقف اطلاق النار تحت عنوان
هدوء مقابل هدوء كي يتجنب ربما الالتزام
باي وقف لاطلاق النار
يبدو ان هناك صافرات انذار
يبدو ان هناك سافرات انذار مجددا
في منطقه
غلاف غزه في
مستوطنه عينها شلوشاه ونيرم نعم اذا
صافرات انذار مجددا زين العابدين في مناطق
غلاف غزه
ايضا دخول الهدنه وكنا نتبع الى هشام بان
نعم عمليا عندما تعود الحياه الى طبيعتها
في غزه فهي تعود الى الحياه غير الطبيعيه
التي تعيشها منذ سنوات عده يعني الغارات
التي ينفذها الجيش الاسرائيلي في غزه لا
تقتصر فقط على جولات التصعيد او على
المعارك او على العمليات التي يعلن عنها
الجيش في غزه وانما ايضا طيله الوقت يتكرر
ان تكون هناك استهدافات من قبل الجيش
الاسرائيلي لمواقع في غزه بين الحين
والاخر وهذا ايضا لا يقتصر على هذه
العمليات وانما على الحصار المتواصل لغزه
منذ سنوات طويله وبالتالي حتى عندما يتم
الاعلان عن وقف لاطلاق النار ونبدا بالقول
ونبدا نرى هذه الصور بالاحتفال التي
بطبيعه الحال يعيشها اهل غزه حاليا بعد
ساعات وصعبه جدا من الغارات والتحليق
المكثف للطيران والتهديد المتواصل بتنفيذ
عمليات اغتيال لكن ايضا في الايام العاديه
تكون بطبيعه الحال غزه معرضه لمثل هذه
الانتهاكات بسبب الوضع الخاص في غزه اذا
بالفعل بالفعل
صافرات الانذار مؤكده الان ربما
في اشكولا ايضا
في جنوب عسقلان
وسفارات الانذار دوت اكثر من مره بعيده
اطلاق وقفه اطلاق النار في مناطق غلاف غزه
وكان هنالك قصف قبيله وقف اطلاق النار
لهذه المنطقه فما الذي يجري الان يعني كل
هذه المهارات التي تداوت فيها صفارات
الانذار الياس كرام هل سقطت فيها الصواريخ
هل كانت هنالك صواريخ او اي قذف من اي نوع
يبدو ان هنالك اطلاق صواريخ بالفعل باتجاه
هذه المناطق في نيرين وعينها شلوشاه وهي
مناطق واقعه الى الجنوب من قطاع غزه في ما
يسمى مجمع اشكول
لم يبلغ عن اصابات حتى هذه الساعه او عن
اعتراضات في تلك المنطقه لكن واضح بان
هنالك كما يبدو قصف صاروخي ونحن نتحدث
حقيقه عن بلدات زين متاخمه جدا
للسياج الامني مع قطاع غزه هذا ياتي بعد
ساعه من الهدوء وبعد ان دخل
اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار حيز التنفيذ ذلك
انه بعد عشر دقائق من ذلك كانت ايضا رشقات
صاروخيه قد شوهدت من خلفنا هنا في منطقه
ازديروت ومنطقه نحل العوز ومنطقه
اياد مردخاي وتصدت القبه الحديديه لبعض
هذه
الصواريخ حقيقه بان هذا الامر غريب زين
همم ذلك ان المقاومه الفلسطينيه كانت
تلتزم دائما بوقف اطلاق النار في الساعه
التي يعلن فيها صحيح بان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه
كثفت من اطلاقاتها الصاروخيه قبل دخول
اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار حيز التنفيذ اي قبل
الساعه العاشره وكان هذا امرا
يعني مبررا ربما او معهودا كما في جولات
سابقه حيث ان المقاومه الفلسطينيه ارادت
ان تثبت ربما للجميع بانها ما زالت قادرين
على تنفيذي ضربات صاروخيه وبانها قدراتها
الصاروخيه لم تتضرر في هذه
الهجمات الاسرائيليه خلال هذا العدوان هل
صدر من الجانب الاسرائيلي
عن اي خرق لهذه لهذا الاتفاق
نعم الجيش الاسرائيلي قال قبل قليل بانه
يؤكد وجود صافرات الانذار في منطقه
غلاف غزه وان الامر قيد التحقيق وقيد
الفحص لكن زين دعنا نشير الى انه احيانا
ما تنطلق صافرات الانذار ايضا بشكل عرضي
وبسبب خلل فني لكن دعنا ننتظر قليلا لنرى
بالفعل ان كانت هنالك صواريخ في تلك
المنطقه لكن ما نستطيع ان نؤكده حقيقه بان
بعد وقف اطلاق النار بدقائق معدوده كان
هنالك استمرار لاطلاق النار في المناطق
الشماليه تحديدا في منطقه ازديروت ومنطقه
هنا في القطاع الشمالي الشرقي للحدود مع
قطاع غزه وهذا يعني يثير كثيرا من
التساؤلات حول ما يجري زين حقيقه بان
استمرار اطلاق النار ربما
سيعقبه ربما اطلاق نار من جانب اسرائيل
لانه في
المره الاولى بعد الساعه العاشره وتسع
دقائق الجيش الاسرائيلي لم يعلن بانه قصف
في غزه ردا على خرق وقف اطلاق النار
ونحن حاولنا ان
نستوضح هذا الامر لكن مصادر الجيش
الاسرائيلي لم ترد علينا
الامر وحتى هذه الساعه ايضا لم نسمع الرد
فعل عسكري من الجانب الاسرائيلي على هذه
الاطلاقات ربما او ذوي الصافراتنا شكرا
جزيلا لك الياس كرام من جنوب عسقلان ونشكر
نجوان سمري من تل ابيب
[تصفيق]
تصمت النيران او هكذا يفترض فتم اتفاق
اخيرا لوقف اطلاق النار بين اسرائيل
والفصائل الفلسطينيه كان مصدر قد قال
للجزيره ان وسط التهدئه قدم صيغه جديده
لوقف متبادل للاطلاق النار في غزه وان
الصيغه الجديده تتضمن وقف استهداف
المدنيين وقصف منازلهم وبحسب المصادر فان
حركه الجهاد وافقت مبدئيا على الصيغه
الجديده في انتظار رد من اسرائيل طالما ان
المقاومه تراكم قوتها هذه الضمانه الوحيده
امامنا ونحن نتوقع كما حدث السابق كما
تقول نتوقع ان اسرائيل ممكن ان ياتي يعني
اي لحظه وتدير ظهرها لاي اتفاق
عن اي اتفاق نتحدث نقرا في موقع اكسيوس ان
المقترح الجديد لوقف اطلاق النار المقدمه
الى كل من اسرائيل والجهاد الاسلامي يختلف
في صيغته عن المقترح السابق ولا تفاصيل
اكثر لكن بغض الطرف عن التفاصيل فحديث
الساعه المحتوم عن التطبيق على الارض
يتساءل متابعون للمشهد الله منذ ايام عن
طرق تثبيت وقف اطلاق النار
ليس معروفا ايضا كيف سيتم التاكد من
التزام الجانبين بما ورد في نص اتفاقهما
وهل تمت اليه واضحه لذلك لا يبدو الامر
يسيرا بالنظر الى الفتره التي استغرقتها
جهود ومحاولات التوصل لتهدئه هل الامر
مختلف هذه المره قد لا يتوافق هذا التوجه
مع نهج التصعيد العسكري الذي اطلقه
الاحتلال في قطاع غزه دون مبرر الامني
المباشر بل مع تلويحه المستمر كذلك بنقل
المواجهه الى مستويات اخرى لكن ابرام
اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار لا يمكن فصله عن
المشهد السياسي والامني في الداخل
الاسرائيلي
ثم ضغوط مورست لا شك على ائتلاف نتنياهو
اليميني كي يضع حدا لما بدا في البدء حتى
في نظر المعارضه الاسرائيليه عمليه صحيحه
وناجحه لكنها ابانت مع الوقت عن كلاف
باهظه لا احد في اسرائيل مستعد كما يبدو
للاستمرار في دفعها ربما كانت تصعيد في
غزه واستئناف عمليات اغتيال قاده المقاومه
رضوخا من نتنياهو لعوتات المتطرفين في
حكومته بما يحفظ تماسكها وربما ساعه حقا
لترميم قوه ردع اسرائيل الاخذه في التاكل
لكن محللين في اسرائيل يرجحون الا تكون
مكاسب نتنياهو من خطوته على قدر توقعاته
فلا يبرا من كل متاعبه الداخليه من خلال
تغيب الاجنده الامنيه وتصدير ازماته
الداخليه بل تجده في المقابل مدفوعا من
النخب السياسيه والاعلاميه وحتى من الشارع
لانهاء التصعيد العسكري
الاكثر نقبه المتاثرين في مستوطنات غلاف
غزه من رد المقاومه القوي والمنسق وكذا
المستشعرين للاعباء الاقتصاديه المتولده
عن التصعيد ولخسائر اخرى اكبر قد
يتكبدونها اذا طالت المواجهه او اتسعت
رقعتها حكومه نتنياهو الائتلافيه احرص من
هؤلاء جميعا كما يبدو على ثلاث حرب من ذلك
القبيل
وينضم الينا من غزه ابراهيم حبيب الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي وينضم الينا من رام الله
الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام
للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه استاذ
ابراهيم حبيب ابراهيم اذا ساعه من الهدنه
لكن ما زالت صفارات الانذار تدوي في مدن
غلاف غزه وجنوب تل ابيب هل من تفسير لذلك
يعني اعتقد انه ربما ما يجري حاليا هو
استكمال لوقف اطلاق النار ربما هناك تفعيل
غير مباشر لبعض
الصواريخ التي كانت جاهزه لعمليه الاطلاق
قبل ان تحدث التهدئه وهناك خلل ما لم يتضح
حتى الان
الرؤيه من
التنظيمات ومن غرفه العمليات المشتركه لكن
الواضح تماما ان غرفه العمليات المشتركه
اعلنت نهايه هذه الجوله وما يجري حاليا او
ما جرى من اطلاق للصواريخ ربما كان بسبب
خلل فني
هذا الاتفاق الذي تم التوصل اليه ينص على
عدم استهداف المنازل الافراد المدنيين
بالنسبه
للجانب الفلسطيني هل يمكن القول انه شرط
وقف الاغتيالات قد تحقق
يعني في هذا الصدد لا يوجد ضامن
للاحتلال عودنا الاحتلال انه لا يمكن ان
يلتزم باي اتفاق او اي هدنه لكن الضامن
الاساسي لاي اتفاق هو قدره المقاومه على
الرد في هذه الجوله تمكنت المقاومه من
ايلام العدو من افشال كل مخططات هذه
الجوله التي رسمها ان تكون قصيره ويحقق
فيها انجاز هذا كله فشل وارتد بشكل عكسي
الاحتلال عندما يقر بشكل واضح انه سيوقف
استهداف الافراد المدنيين والمساكن
المدنيه هو اقرار بانه ارتكب جريمه حرب
وانه ضمنا توقف عن عمليه الاغتيالات لكنه
لا يريد ان يصرح ذلك علنا حتى لا يخسر
سياسيا امام الجماهير الاسرائيليه واعتقد
انه هذا الامر سيكون
لاحقا وستكون هناك الكثير من التساؤلات
لما جرى حول وقف اطلاق النار في اسرائيل
يعني الفرحه الع ارمه التي شاهدنا في قطاع
غزه لم نشهد مثل في الجانب الاسرائيلي
برايك لماذا
لانه الجميع مقتنع ان هناك انجاز او غرفه
العمليات المشتركه التي قادت هذه العمليه
كانت من اكبر انجازات الحاله الفلسطينيه
هذه الغرفه المشتركه التي يجب ان تشكل
نوالي الوحده الوطنيه الفلسطينيه هذه
الغرفه المشتركه التي قادت المعركه
باقتدار كان هناك مشاركه حقيقيه اقتناع
بالاستراتيجيه التي تبنتها موافقه وعمل
مشترك من كافه الفصائل الفلسطينيه تنسيق
ومتابعه من الجميع تكتيكات جديده تستخدمها
المقاومه ارهقت الجبهه الداخليه
الاسرائيليه ضربت على نقاط الضعف
الاستراتيجي استطاعت ان تحجم القبه
الحديديه التي كانت تتباهى بها اسرائيل كل
هذه الامور كانت محل فخر واعتزاز من قبل
المواطنين الفلسطينيين الذين التفوا حقيقه
حول المقاومه وهم يدركون تماما انها حققت
لم يكن مطلوبا من المقاومه ان تحقق انتصار
في هذه الجوله بقدر ما كان مطلوبا منها ان
تفشل اهداف العدو في هذه الجوله وان تبقى
ثابته وتعزز من مكانتها وقوتها لاداره
المعركه افشلت كل الاهداف الثلاثه
الاساسيه لهذه الجوله
استاذ حبيب بالنسبه لاداره المعركه يعني
صرح لنا محمد الهندي رئيس الدائره
السياسيه للجهاد الاسلامي بان المعركه
الجهاد كانت في الميدان والدور الفصائل
الاخرى عبر غرفه العمليات المشتركه هو
توفير الغطاء فقط ماذا نفهم من ذلك
غرفه العمليات المشتركه ينضوي تحتها كل
الفصائل الفلسطينيه بما فيها الجهاد
الاسلامي لكن في هذه الجوله تم تصدير
الجهاد الاسلامي كونه هو المستهدف من هذه
العمليه وكل الفصائل الفلسطينيه كانت
تتولى عمليه الدعم والاسناد ولا يخفى ذلك
على احد وقد تحدث بذلك الدكتور محمد
الهندي مباشره بان كل الفصائل بما فيها
كتاب القسام موجوده في الميدان غرفه
العمليات المشتركه في بيانها الاخير قالت
نحن من بدانا المعركه وهي من ختمت المعركه
وبالتالي نتحدث عن جهد جماعي لا نتحدث عن
جهد فردي وبالتالي خرجت هذه الجوله بابها
حله وابها صوره كان كل الشعب الفلسطيني
راضي عنها عن ادائها عن ما انجزته في هذه
الجوله شكرا جزيلا لك من غزه حبيبي
ابراهيم الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اتوجه الى
ضيفي من رام الله دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي
هذه الجوله انتهت
بعد خمسه ايام من قصف اسرائيل بداه الجانب
الاسرائيلي باغتيال قيادات الصف الاول في
سرايا القدس ما الذي تغير في الجانب
الفلسطيني بعد هذه الجوله
شكرا لك اولا اسمح لي ان اتوجه لشعبنا
الفلسطيني وخاصه اهلنا في قطاع غزه
بالتهنئه لانتصارهم على العدوان
الاسرائيلي لانهم افشلوا هذا العدوان
وثانيا كل التحيه للمقاومه الفلسطينيه
الباسله وللاخوه في حركه الجهاد الاسلامي
الذين صمدوا رغم التضحيات الغاليه التي
قدموها وثالثا نحيي ذكرى شهدائنا الذين
استشهدوا في هذه المعركه 33 شهيد اصبحوا
جزءا من 250 شهيد استشهدوا في الضفه وقطاع
غزه منذ بدايه هذا العام
ونتمنى للجرحى لحوم حوالي 100 الان في
قطاع غزه معظمهم من الاطفال والنساء
الشفاء العاجل
واريد ان اوجه شكر للحقيقه لقناه الجزيره
على تغطيها المتواصله والمستمره لهذه
المعركه التي انتهت بهذا الانتصار
اريد ان اشدد نعم تغير اشياء كثيره اهم
شيء ان المخططات الاسرائيليه فشلت فشلت
اسرائيل في وقف المقاومه اريد ان اؤكد ان
لماذا اقول هذا انتصار لانه الهدف المركزي
لحكومه اسرائيل كان ان تصل الى وضع تهدئه
من جانب واحد بمعنى ان تستمر في الاستيطان
والاحتلال والضم والقمع والقتل
والاعتقالات ولا تكون هناك مقاومه
فلسطينيه ان ترضع المقاومه الفلسطينيه في
الضفه الغربيه قبل قطاع غزه هذا هو هدف
الضربات التي وجهت لقاده الجهاد الاسلامي
والنتيجه فشل لم يوقفوا المقاومه ولن
يوقفوا المقاومه على الاطلاق الامر الثاني
فشلوا في فصل الساحات عن بعضها البعض
والامر الثالث فشلوا في الاستفراد بحركه
الجهاد الاسلامي بسبب الالتفاف والوحده
التي ظهرت من قبل كل القوى الفلسطينيه
والامر الرابع ظهر فشل العسكري يعني القبه
الذي يتكرر فشلها اكثر من مره وهذا سيكلف
اسرائيل كثيرا ليس فقط لانها فشلت لانها
ستخسر صفقات عسكريه كثيره كانت تخطط لها
من خلال بيع هذه المنظومه واريد ان اشدد
ايضا ان سياسه الاغتيالات قد فشلت فمكان
كل قائد استشهد جاء عشره قاده اخرون ومكان
كل فلسطيني مقاوم يقتل سواء كان في الضفه
الغربيه او قطاع غزه يتقدم مئه شاب
ليحملوا سلاحهم وبالتالي سياسه الاغتيالات
كما فشلت في سابقا فشلت الان ايضا واهم
شيء انهم فشلوا في كسر الردع الفلسطيني
الردع بقي حتى بعد ان اعلن حتى بعد ان
اعلن وقف اطلاق النار انا برايي في نقطه
اخيره بس لا اريد ان اطيل ولكن نقطه مهمه
جدا ان هذه المعركه اكثر من اي معركه اخرى
في السابق كشفت مدى هشاشه المجتمع
الاسرائيلي لا يحتمل معركه لا يحتمل خسائر
بشريه لا يحتمل خسائر اقتصاديه وبالتاكيد
لا يحتمل خسائر معنويه وبالتالي المحصله
العامه لا انا اريد ان يشعر شعبنا بالفخر
والاعتزاز هو لم يحرر الضفه الغربيه طبعا
ولم يكن منتظرا ان يفعل ذلك ولكنه انتصر
على الذين ارادوا ان يكسروا مقاومته
انتصارا رائعا يسجل في تاريخه النضالي
ويسجل في تاريخه الكفاحي وكما ذكرتم هذه
جوله انتهت ولكننا في نضال مفتوح وفي صراع
مستمر حتى نحقق حريتنا الكامله وننهي
الاحتلال وكل منظومه الاضطهاد العنصريه
الاسرائيلي انت ذكرت الضفه الغربيه ونحن
كنا قد سالنا
مشاهدينا ومتابع موقعنا على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي قبل الحصاد عن رايهم في مقالات
الاوضاع بعد الاعلان الوقفه اطلاق النار
في غزه 72% من المصوطين قالوا ان ذلك
سيعقبه مزيد من التصعيد في الضفه الغربيه
يعني اذا كان كما تفضلت ما حدث في غزه هو
لكسر ما يجري في الضفه الغربيه فان غالبيه
من يصوتون يرون ان الضفه الغربيه ستكون
مركزا لمزيد من التصعيد من الجانب
الاسرائيلي في الايام المقبله ما رايك
[موسيقى]
انا اوافق على ذلك انهم سيصعدوا هجماتهم
لانه في اسرائيل حكومه فاشيه حكومه فاشيه
عنصريه هي الاسوا في تاريخ هذه المنطقه
وهؤلاء المجرمون يعلنوا دون هوادا ودون
اخفاء ودون تضليل ودون ان يخفوا مقاصدهم
ان هدفهم ضم الضفه الغربيه وتهويدها وسم
يقول امام الشعب الفلسطيني واحد من ثلاث
احتمالات اما ان يرحل او يرضخ بالكامل
للمنظومه الفاشيه الاسرائيليه او يقتل
ويموت هذا هذا راي الحكومه الاسرائيلي
ونحن نعرف ذلك ونعرف اننا نقاوم هذا
الهجوم ونعرف ان الشعب الفلسطيني في الضفه
صامت كما هو في قطاع غزه وسيناضل دفاعا عن
حقوقه ولن تنجح اسرائيل لن تنجح هذه
الهجمه الفاشيه ولكن طبعا التصعيد قائم
ولكن هل ستتوقف المقاومه بالعكس المقاومه
تتعزز وتترسخ لانه يترسخ لدى الشعب
الفلسطيني باسره قناعه عميقه
طرق السابقه فشلت اوسلو فشل نهج التفاوض
فشل نهج المراهنه على تدخل امريكيا فشل
وراينا الانحياز الامريكي في هذه المره
ايضا شكرا الشعب الفلسطيني باسره مقتنع
اليوم بان الطريق الوحيد هو المقاومه
والكفاح وان الاحتلال لا يرضع الا
بالمقاومه وفرض العقوبات والمقاطعه عليه
اشكرك شكرا جزيلا الدكتور مصطفى البرغوث
الامين العامد المبادره الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه ضيفنا من رام الله
ومن النصر ينضم الينا جاكي خوري الخبير في
الشؤون الاسرائيليه يعني شاهدنا كما قلت
للدكتور مصطفى وكما قلت لضيوفنا فرحه في
غزه لم تقابلها فرحه في اسرائيل لماذا
اسمعك سؤال مره اخرى تابعنا بعد دخول هذه
هذا الوقف الاطلاق النار حيز التنفيذ في
العشره من مساء اليوم بتوقيت مكه المكرمه
شاهدنا افراحا
واحتفاءا واحتفالا في غزه لكن لم نشاهد
شيئا مماثلا في اسرائيل لماذا
يعني اعتقد ان المشهد هنا مختلف بالنسبه
لاسرائيل الموضوع ليس من يحتفل ويخرج هلال
الى الشوارع السؤال الان يعني ماذا بعد
بالنسبه للتجمعات السكانيه
المحيطه طبعا بغزه وهل سيعود هذا المشهد
ويتكرر مره اخرى خلال فتره قصيره لا ننسى
ان بعد يعني ما حدث هذه الليله بانتظارنا
خلال الايام القريبه القادره تحديات اذا
كان ما يرتبط بمسيره الاعلام في القدس
وكيف سيكون التعامل مع هذه المسيره بكل
تداعياتها ثانيا هل سيكون هنالك فعلا
التزام بكل شروط التهدئه التي تم التوصل
اليها في مساله مثلا الاغتيالات وغير ذلك
كيف سيترجم هذا بالنسبه يعني المواطن
الاسرائيلي بكل تداعيات هذا المشهد خلال
الفتره القريبه وبال يعني انا لا اقول ان
الشعور في اسرائيل هو شعور هزيمه ولكن
ايضا لا نتحدث عن شعور وكانه هنالك امور
حسمت بمعنى نحن امام
قارن هذا الشعور او هذا الموقف الليله هذا
الصمت
بالحروب السابقه على غزه حينما كان يجلس
الاسرائيلي على الحدود ليشاهد الطائرات
وهي تقصف والمنازل وهي تحترق هذا غير
موجود في هذه الجوله
اولا ولا نتحدث عن الحرب بالمفهوم الذي
كان مثلا قبل سنوات اذا اخذنا ما حصل في
العام 2014 فهذا اولا ثانيا قال له الراي
العام الاسرائيلي يعني يفهم قضيه مهمه ان
هذه المواجهه كانت بالاساس مع تنظيم هكذا
يعني تم تصدير هذه المعلومه له بشكل متكرر
من خلال مكتب رئيس الحكومه من خلال
المناطق بلسان الجيش ان هذه الحمله او هذه
المعركه او هذه المواجهه كانت بالاساس مع
حركه الجهاد الاسلامي وما برز ايضا في هذه
المعركه ان العديد من قيادات الجهاد
الاسلامي تحديدا الذراع العسكري تم
اغتيالهم في بيوتهم وهذه رساله ايضا وصلت
وتغلغلت الى الراي العام الاسرائيلي ثالثا
وهذا الاهم ان القضيه الابرزيه ليست فقط
مع الجهاد الاسلامي وانما هنالك حركه اخرى
وانا اتحدث الان بالمنطق الاسرائيلي ويجب
ان يكون واضح هذا الامر ان هنالك حركه
حماس بك وادرها العسكريه بمؤسساتها بمعنى
الامور في قطاع غزه لم تتغير الان بتحول
استراتيجي وكانه هنالك شيء كبير تطور في
في القطاع بفعل ايام الاخيره القراءه
الفلسطينيه هنا مختلفه دائما كان هنالك
تضارب في روايتين الروايه الاسرائيليه
والروايه الفلسطينيه وبالتالي في بعض
الاحيان المخارج بالنسبه لكل طرف مختلفه
تماما انا اقول لك بصريح العباره اذا
وافقنا لم نوافق بالنسبه لاسرائيل واعتقد
غدا هذا الامر سيبرز من خلال يعني ما
تعودنا عليه ان يقوم مثلا رئيس الحكومه
ويكون قائد الاركان وقاده الاجهزه الامنيه
بعمليه يعني ايصال الرسائل للمراقبين
والمحالين والمتابعين لهيك عن نتائج هذه
المعركه وخاصه ابراز قضيه استهداف
القيادات البارزه في المؤسسه العسكريه
لحركه الاسلامي انا على ثقه انه غدا صباحا
العناوين ستكون ان الجهاد لسان متعرض
لضربه قويه في مؤسسته العسكريه وهنالك
نجاح في تحديد حركه حماس مره اخرى
وبالتالي يعني القراءه في اسرائيل مختلفه
ولكن كما ذكرت بالنسبه
كيف يمكن تبريرها وتفسيرها
نعم موضوع القبه الحديديه جزئيه مهمه
بمعنى انه في هذه يعني المواجهه ثبت ان
هنالك خلل في هذه المنظومه من ناحيه اسقاط
عدد كبير من الصواريخ التي اطلقت من قطاع
غزه هل الخلل هو في المنظومه الحسابيه
التابعه للاجهزه التقنيات في هذه المنظومه
ام هنالك استراتيجيه اتبعتها القصوى من
خلال اطلاق عدد كبير جدا من الصواريخ في
ان الواحد وعلامات النقطه ولكن في اسرائيل
سيكون هنالك مثلا تفعيل ما يعرف بمقله هذه
ايضا منظومه جديده دخلت على المعركه ولكن
تحديدا في منطقه القدس في منطقه تل ابيب
باعتبارها مناطق استراتيجيه وايضا اعتقد
ان اسرائيل
ذهبت في موضوع التجربه اسلحه وادوات جديده
في هذه المعركه الطائرات المسيره
الانتحاريه الاستهداف مثلا في موضوع
البيوت والاصول مباشره الى هناك فاعتقد
انه في اسرائيل لا يوجد شعور بان هنالك
معركه خاسره ولكن شعور ان الامور قد حسمت
بمعنى هم يعرفون جيدا معركه واحده من
مسلسل قد يكون يعني خلال فتره وجيزه بمعنى
ان الامور ليست واضحه ولن تحسم بشكل يدفع
المواطن الاسرائيلي اما للخروج للشارع
ليحتفل واما للخروج للشارع ليحتاج على
حكومته انا اقول لك انه خلال ايام يعني
اعتقد في منتصف الاسبوع القادم عندما تعود
الكنيست الى عملها سنعود الى مسلسل
الاحتجاجات سنعود الى المسلسل الداخلي
سنعود الى النقاشات في الكنيسه
المحور هل يمكن تقول طبعا ان الراي العامل
الاسرائيليه يتم تهيئته يتم تغذيته من قبل
ما تقوله الحكومه وتقوله المؤسسات الامنيه
لكن هل يمكن حجب نص ما تسرب بالنص هذا
الاتفاق عن موافقه الجانبين على وقف
استهداف المدنيين ووقف هدم استهداف
المنازل
والافراد ما يعني الرضوخ في راي على الاقل
في راي الفصائل الفلسطينيه لمطلب الفصائل
بوقف الاغتيالات
نعم ولكن يعني هنالك ايضا يعني جزئيه اخرى
اولا موضوع الهدم البيوت او استهداف
البيوت واستهداف المدنيين يعني القراءه في
طلبه هنالك هدوء ولا يوجد اطلاق صواريخ من
غزه باتجاه الاراضي الاسرائيليه فنحن لسنا
بحاجه الى موضوع هدم البيوت او استهداف
البيوت وكذلك يعني استهداف المدنيه بمعنى
هذا يرتبط بمعادله الهدوء مقابل الهدوء
وبالتالي لا نتحدث عن شيء جديد دخل على
ميزان الردع في هذا الموضوع قضيه الافراد
او الاغتيالات وهنا يجب ان ننتبه الى
المصطلحات يعني نحن نتحدث عن استهداف
الافراد في اسرائيل يقولون هذا الكلام غير
موجود واعتقد انه هنا يعني قد نجد مساحه
لكل طرف ان يؤكد على موقفه بمعنى لدى
الفصائل في غزه وتحديدا الجهاد يقولون
هنالك التزام اسرائيل تقول ولكن ما سيحسم
الامر هو الميدان وسنتابع كيف سيكون
الميدان نشكرك شكرا جزيلا جاكي خوري
الخبير في الشؤون الاسرائيليه ضيفنا من
الناصره
[موسيقى]
انتخاباتهم المصريه تشهدها تركيا بعد
ساعات قليله من الان انتخابات بطعم
الاستفتاء على النظام الرئاسي تخوضها
المعارضه وكذلك على حكم العداله والتنميه
زميل جلال شاهد في اسطنبول مع شبكه
مراسلين في مختلف الولايات التركيه
ليقربون من المشهد الانتخابيه عشيه انطلاق
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه
ثماني ساعات فقط تفصلنا عن انطلاق اهم
استحقاق تشهد تركيا الجمهوريه مع عبورها
الى مئويتها الثانيه انتخابات رئاسيه
وبرلمانيه تتسم بطابع الاستفتاء على
النظام الرئاسي وحكم العداله والتنميه
بزعامه الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان منذ حوالي
20 عاما توصف الاجواء الانتخابيه عشيه
الاقتراع بانها الاكثر سخونه منذ عقود حيث
تستهدف المعارضه كتله الشباب التي لا تعرف
حكما سوى حكم العداله والتنميه والرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان يقابلها تمسك قطاعات
واسعه من الناخبين بالرئيس اردوغان الساعي
الى ولايه رئاسيه ثانيه يفترض ان تكون
الاخيره بموجب الدستور انتخابات مصيريه
لتحالف الشعب المعارض ومرشحه كمال كريشتار
اوغلو ولتحالف الجمهور الحاكم ومرشحه رجب
طيب اردوغان خصماني لدودان يرى الاول ان
فرصه لتوليه السلطه وسانحه في هذه المرحله
لعوامل داخليه وخارجيه بينما اثبت الثاني
في استحقاقات سابقه قدرته على الحسم وان
هزمته ليست سهله سنكون معكم من استوديو
تغطيه الجزيره الخاصه للانتخابات التركيه
في اسطنبول رفقه شبكه مراسلين المنتشرين
في مختلف الولايات التركيه نقربكم من
المشهد الانتخابي والسباق نحو الرئاسه
وعضويه البرلمان فمن سيعبر بتركيا الى
مئويتها الثانيه
اذا يستعد اكثر من 60 مليون من الناخبين
الاتراك للتوجه الى صناديق الاقتراع صباح
غد الاحد لانتخاب رئيس جليد للبلاد يعبر
بالجمهوريه نحو مئويتها الثانيه اضافه الى
600 نائب يشكلون البرلمان الجديد ومنذ
الساعه السادسه من مساء اليوم بالتوقيت
المحلي دخلت تركيا مرحله الصمت الانتخابي
بشكل رسمي حيث تم حظر الدعايه الانتخابيه
بكل اشكالها يتنافس على منصب الرئاسه
الرئيس التركي الحالي ومرشح تحالف الجمهور
رجب طيب اردوغان الذي يطمح الى الفوز
بولايه ثانيه واخيرا بعد تحول البلاد الى
النظام الرئاسي ومرشح تحالف الشعب وزعيم
حزب الشعب الجمهوري كمال كريشتار اوغلو
ومرشح تحالف الاجداد سنان اوغان وكان مرشح
حزب البلد محرم انجي قد قرر الانسحاب امس
الجمعه من السباق الرئاسي ويتنافس اربعه
وعشرون حزبا سياسي على المقاعد 600
الممثله في البرلمان التركي
[موسيقى]
تضم الينا شبكه مراسلينا من اسطنبول احمد
فال ولد الدين من انقره المعتز بلا حسن من
ازمير عمر الحاج مرحبا بكم جميعا احمد فال
طبعا كلا الطرفين لاسيما كالجدار اوغلو
ورجب طيب اردوغان يعولان على فئه الشباب
في هذه الانتخابات كيف يقارب كل فريق
مخاطبه هذه الفئه
نعم جلال هذه الانتخابات التي صمتت
اصواتها الصاخبه قبل خمس ساعات من الان
محوريه جدا ولعل اهم فئه حرجه ستتعاطى مع
هذه الانتخابات ويحرص كلا الطرفين على خطب
ودها هي فئه الشباب
وهناك فئه حوالي خمس ملايين سيصوتون للمره
الاولى هم يعني بلغوا ثمانيه عشر عاما في
هذه الانتخابات هذه الفئه التي تبلغ حوالي
خمس ملايين وتمثل ثمانيه بالمئه من مجموع
ناخب هذه الكتله الحرجه هي هي التي يتنافس
عليها الفريقان خلال الايام الماضيه جلال
تحدثوا مع هذه الفئه قابلتهم تحدثت اليهم
عن طموحاتهم لاحظت ان ثمه انقساما حادا
تشده هذه الفئه بدورها كما تشده بقيه
تركيا لكن اهم شيء كان في اذهانهم من خلال
احاديث معهم هو موضوع الاقتصاد يبدو فعلا
ان الاشكاليه الاقتصاديه من اهم العوامل
التي ستحدد من سيحكم تركيا خلال فتره
القادمه
هو ايضا من هذه الفئه ان التواصل
الاجتماعي التعاطي مع التواصل الاجتماعي
ما ينشر في الانترنت يؤثر في هذه الفئه
جدا فمعظم معلوماتها من خلال ما فهمته من
احاديث معها ياتي عن طريق شبكات التواصل
الاجتماعي وهذا تحدي لاحظه كلا المرشحان
الرئيس الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان وزعيم
المعارضه كمالك
كلاهما حرص من خلال حملته طيله الاسبوعين
الماضيين على ظهور عبر وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي ومحاوله ومخاطبه هذه الفئه هذه
الفئه الشبابيه جلال تتميز بامر لافت ايضا
وهو انها لم تعايش تركيا القديمه انما
ولدت لحزب العداله والتنميه وبالتالي هي
لا تعرف حزبا اخر وبالتالي ربما يرى
ابناء العداله والحريه انها ينقصها الوعي
حسب رايهم فيما يتعلق بطبيعه حكم حزب
العداله والتنميه لانهم لم يروا تركيا قبل
نهضتها الاقتصاديه خلال العشرين عاما للم
اضيه وبالتالي هذه الفئه بدورها بما انها
محوريه هي ايضا منقسمه يمكنك ان ترى
ورائها اولاء الشباب الاتراك كغيرهم من
خلال احاديثنا معهم مشغولون
ومقسمون بين اتجاهين وحده وغدا ان شاء
الله يوم الاحد هو الذي سيحدد طبيعته هذه
الفئه وموقفها ولمن ستصوت وهي كما اسلفنا
تبلغ حوالي ثمانيه بالمئه من مجموع
الاصوات وكلاء الطرفين حريص على ان
يخاطبها جلال
ذكرت العامل الاقتصادي المعتز بالله حسن
في انقره الاقتصاد كان ملفا دسما اذا صح
التعبير في الحملات الانتخابيه كيف تقاربه
الاحزاب المتنافسه في هذه الانتخابات
نعم جلال الاقتصاد وملف الاقساط تحديدا هو
من اهم الملفات في هذه الانتخابات خصوصا
وان تركيا عانت في الفتره الاخيره من تضخم
كبير وصلت وصل الى نسب مرتفعه وايضا موجد
غلاء للاسعار وبالتالي كان هذا الامر هو
من احد اهم الامور التي
ركزت عليها
الاحزاب والتحالفات الانتخابيه حزب تحالف
الرئيس التركي كان وعد بان يكون هناك تطور
في معالجه التضخم والاقتصاد كنت التقيت
عدد من
الاشخاص الاقتصاديين في هذا الجانب وقالوا
ان وبعد الانتخابات سيكون هناك تركيز على
زياده الانتاج والمعروض في قطاعات الطاقه
والغذاء والعقارات وبالتالي ايضا في
التحالف المقابل تحالف المعارضه الذين
التقيتهم من هذا التحالف ايضا اكدوا على
ان السبب في ما وصلت اليه البلاد من الوضع
الاقتصادي هو حكومه الرئيس اردوغان
وبالتالي هم
ما يجب
القيام به لاصلاحه دون ان يكون هناك
تحديد
للبرنامج الاقتصادي سوى انه سيكون هناك
اداره اقتصاديه تعتمد الاسس العلميه في
مواجهه الاقتصاد وبالتالي هذا الملف
الاقتصادي هو ملفهم خصوصا وان هناك كما
ذكرت نسب تضخم عاليه كانت في الفتره
الاخيره والطرفان يعدان بان يقوم بحل هذه
المشكله
طيب عمر الحاج متواجد في ازمير معروف عن
ازمير بانها معقل المعارضه معقل حزب الشعب
الجمهوري الذي يدعو الى عوده اللاجئين
لسيما اللاجئين السوريين الى سوريا كيف
يقارب الحزب عمر الحاج هذا الملف وايضا
الاحزاب الاخرى كيف تنظر اليه
نعم جلال كما هي كل الملفات وكل المشاكل
هناك تناقض كبير بين رؤيه والمقاربه التي
يقدمها كل جانب على حساب مقاربته الجانب
الاخر في هذا الموضوع بالتحديد كان الرئيس
اردوغان قد سئل قبل يوم واحد عند اجتماعه
مع الشباب عن موضوع اللاجئين وحتى كان
السؤال بلهجه الامتعاض ربما او حتى
الانزعاج من الفتره الطويله التي قضاها
اللاجئون هنا خاصه
اللاجئون السوريون كان اجابه الرئيس
اردوغان هي
المقاربه التي اتبعت تبع حزب العداله
والتنميه والذي قال ببساطه ان الحرب هناك
لم تنتهي وان هناك
خطرا على حياه هؤلاء ولكنه اشار الى ان
الحكومه تسعى الى تطبيق عوده طواعيه الى
طوعيه لهؤلاء اللاجئين ولكن وانها تهيئ
تحاول ان تهيئ تهيئ لهم الظروف واسباب
البقاء واشار الى المشروعات التي قامت بها
الحكومه وايضا
ايضا ينضم الينا من ديار بكر وليد العطار
ديار بكر معقل المكون الكردي في تركيا
تحديدا حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي وليد اطلعنا
على الاجواء الانتخابيه مع دخول تركيا ما
يعرف بالصمت الانتخابي عشيه الاقتراع
نعم جلال هذا الميدان الذي اقف فيه قبل
ساعات الصمت الانتخابي كان يعج
بالدعايه الانتخابيه لمختلف التحالفات
والاحزاب التركيه عندما وصلنا اليه بعد
السادسه مساء وجدناه خاويا تقريبا من كل
وسائل الدعايه صمت انتخابي كامل في
الدعايه المتحركه والدعايه الثابته هذا
هذه الان اجواء ترقب تعيش تحيئه تنتظرها
ديار بكر انتظارا لسعه بدء ساعات الاقتراع
في الثامنه صباحا هناك مليون ومئه الف
واربعمائه واربعون مليون ومائه واربعه
الفا تقريبا من الناخبين سيتوجهون الى
ثلاثه الاف
و675 صندوقا للانتخابات المكون الكردي هو
حجر زاويه وبيضه قبان كما يقال في هذه
الانتخابات كل التحالفات تسعى لاستقطابه
باصواته تحالف الجمهور الحاكم تحالف مع
حزب هدى المحافظ في مقابل تحالف غير معلن
كونه وانشاه تحالف الشعب المعارض مع حزب
الشعوب الديمقراطي الذي لن يخوض هذه
الانتخابات مباشره ولكن من خلال حزب
اليسار الاخضر كل هذه التداخلات السياسيه
في مقابل او يقابلها على الجانب الشعبي في
الشارع مع الناس الذين لقيناهم خلال
الايام الماضيه اشكالات البطاله اشكالات
قله فرص العمل التي شكى لنا منها كثير من
السكان هنا هذه الضغوط الاقتصاديه
والتداخلات السياسيه ستفرز
مؤكد ستفرد شيئا كثيرا في صناديق الاقتراع
يوم الاحد صباح الغد بعد عده ساعات من
الان
صحيح شكرا لشبكه مراسلينا وليد عطار في
ديار بكر عمر الحاج في ازمير المعتز بالله
حسن في انقره واحمد الدين في اسطنبول طبعا
لنا موعد معكم في صباح الغد مع فتح صناديق
الاقتراع هنا في استوديو الجزيره لتغطيه
الانتخابات ينضم الينا ايضا مدير مكتب
الجزيره عبد العظيم محمد عبد العظيم لافت
انه لا مظاهر انتخابيه في خلفيه المراسلين
وهذا لانه مرحله الصمت الانتخابي وانا
لاحظت فعلا يعني في طريقي الى الى المكتب
لاحظت ان كل الصور وكل الشعارات رفعت
تماما وهذا التزام تام بما يعرف بالصمت
الانتخابي هذا يفرض
المجلس الاعلى للانتخابات في تركيا يفرض
على جميع الناخبين والمرشحين
والاحزاب برفع شعاراتها والتوقف عن
الدعايه الانتخابيه حتى الحديث الى وسائل
الاعلام وبع
[موسيقى]
السياسيين المرشحين خصوصا اردوغان اوغلو
لم يستطيعوا ان يتحدثوا قاموا بجولات بدون
حديث مثلا
اردوغان ذهب الى جامع صوفيا وذهب لصلاه
المغرب واجتمع عدد الاف من الحشود كمارك
ذهب لزياره قبر
اتاتورك في اشارات رمزيه من كلا الطرفين
لخلفيتهم ولي اهدافهم ولمشاريعهم التي
يقدموها للجمهور التركي وهي هذه اخر
الرسائل التي حاولت المرشحان توصيلها
للجمهور التركي في بعد عمليه الصمت
الانتخاب استطلاعات رايي كثيره شاهدناها
منذ حوالي ربما شهر
وبعضها متضارب بعضها متقارب اخر هذه
الاستطلاعات الى ماذا وصلت طبعا جلال
تعرفه نحن منذ اسبوع سويه ونواكب كل هذه
الاستطلاعات الراي استطلاعات الراي
لا يمكن الركون الى استطلاعات الراي في
تركيا باعتبار ان كل مراكز التي تقوم بها
الاستطلاعات هي تابعه للاحزاب بشكل مباشر
او غير مباشر خلال الايام الماضيه
الاستطلاعات المراكز القريبه من حزب
العداله والتنميه تظهر تقدم
اردوغان على منافسه بثلاثه واربعه نقاط
واعلى استطل عربي اعطاه خلال اسبوع الماضي
هو خمسين فاصل نصف او اربعه
المئه
واستطلاعات القريبه من حزب العداله
والتنميه بالجدار اوغلو من تحالف الشعب
ايضا كانت تعطي
كجدار التقدم في كل استطلاعات الراي واعلى
نسبه اعطته هي 51 ونصف في استطلاعه الراي
وهذا يؤشر على تقارب المرشحين في هذه
المنافسه وان الخيارات مفتوحه والتقارب
مفتوح اريد ان نشير فقط الى ان
اخر استطلاعات الراي الغير معلنه
استطلاعات راي معلنه تقدم الجمهور وهناك
استطلاعات راي غير معلنه تقوم بها الاحزاب
صحيح اخر استطلاع رايي قدم قبل
بضع ساعات اي بعد الصمت الانتخابي الى
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان قام بحزب العداله
والتنميه اعطاه ما نسبته 48 ونصف الى 49
هذه اعلى نسبه سيحصل عليها الرئيس وقالوا
ان استطلاعاتهم التي شملت 20 مدينه سته
الاف
مواطن
جدار اخرى واخذ
45% والترجيحات تقول انهم سيذهبون الى
جوله ثانيه في الانتخابات وان اصوات محرمه
ان جاء ستذهب معظمها الى الذين انسحب من
الانتخابات ستذهب
وقسم منها سيذهب الى سنان اوغن الذي تقدم
منذ امس واليوم الى خمسه فاصله سبعه
بالعشره اي انه
محرم انجا في معظمها ذهبت الى سنان اوغان
وهو من سيدفع يبدو انه هو من سيدفع
الطرفين للذهاب الى جوله ثانيه في
الاقتراع نوضح للمشاهدين لماذا جوله ثانيه
لان كل مرشح يحتاج الى اكثر من خمسين
بالمئه لكي يفوز ويحسن من الجوله الاولى
البرامج الانتخابيه سواء كانت الرئاسيه او
التشريعيه كانت مختلفه عبد العظيم يعني
بالتاكيد هناك برامج مختلفه
يركز على الجانب الاقتصادي وعلى العوده
بتركيا لهويتها القديمه والتوجه نحو الغرب
بينما
اردوغان
يتحدث عن ايضا برامج اقتصاديه
ومشروع
بداه سيكمله في خلال السنوات الخمس
القادمه وانه يؤكد على دور تركيا محوري في
المنطقه والمحيط الاقليمي والمحيط الدولي
لكن جلال وانت ايضا ممكن لاحد خلال الايام
الماضيه
المرشحون
المتنافسون بعيدا عن كل هذه البرامج
الانتخابيه هناك حاله استقطاب صحيح في
الشارع التركي لا علاقه لها بالبرامج
الانتخابيه هناك من سيذهب لصناديق
الاقتراع بغض النظر عن كيف سيكون البرنامج
الانتخابي ربما ستكون اعلى نسبه مشاركه
تصل الى 90% وهي نسب خياليه في تركيا
وربما التحالفات غير المتجانسه تفرض ما
تفضلت به شكرا لك عبد العظيم محمد مكتب
الجزيره في تركيا شكرا لشبكه مراسلين
النافذه موعدنا يتجدد في اطلالات اخرى
بدايه من صباح الغد مع فتح صناديق
الاقتراع كونوا معنا دائما في هذه التغطيه
الخاصه للانتخابات التركيه من مكتب
واستوديو الجزيره في اسطنبول
شكرا جلال وشبكه مراسلينا راس الساعه وهذا
التذكير بمواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
بعد خمسه ايام من تصعيد اسرائيلي في غزه
واستهداف مواقع وقيادات الجهاد الاسلامي
ورد تصاعدي من غرفه عمليات المقاومه في
الداخل الاسرائيلي اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار
في قطاع غزه يدخل حيزه تنفيذ يتضمن وقف
قتل المدنيين والافراد وتدمير المنازل
وقياديهم بالجهاد يقول للجزيره انه تم
اطلاع كافه الفصائل على تفاصيله وان
الضمانات هي في وحده المقاومه
في تركيا وعشيه انتخابات رئاسيه وبرلمانيه
مصيريه صمت انتخابي وتاهب امني يسبق توجه
اكثر من 60 مليون ناخب الى صناديق
الاقتراع منافسه محتدمه بين التحالف
الجمهور الحاكم التحالف الشعب المعارض
والمؤشرات تمنح المرشحين فرصا متساويه
بالتزامن مع اشتباكات باسلحه ثقيله في
الخرطوم بحري ومدرمان مصادر سودانيه تكشف
للجزيره عن بدء مفاوضات جديده بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع غدا الاحد في
جده بواسطه امريكيه سعوديه لتثبيت الهدنه
واخلاء المنشات الصحيه من المقاتلين وفتح
ممرات امنه تمهيدا لوقف دائم لاطلاق النار
[موسيقى]
يخيم اذا هدوء حذر على الاجواء في غزه بعد
نحو ساعه من دخول اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار
حيث التنفيذ بين الجانبين الفلسطيني
والاسرائيلي وقد تم اطلاقه دفعات صواريخ
من القطاع قبلت برد اسرائيلي بعد دقائق من
موعد بدء تنفيذ الاتفاق قبل ساعتين من
الان وقد انهى هذا الاتفاق تصعيد
الاسرائيليا استمر خمسه ايام وبدا باغتيال
عدد من قيادي الجهاد الاسلامي واستهداف
مواقع ومنشات ومباني الجهاد في غزه بجانب
مباني اخرى وقد ردت فصائل المقاومه بشكل
منسق ضمن ما يعرف بغرفه عمليات المقاومه
وكانت الاحداث قد تسارعت مساء السبت بعد
الاعلان عن تقديم الوسطاء صيغه جديده
للاتفاق بين الجانبين تتضمن وقف استهداف
المدنيين وهدم المنازل واستهداف الافراد
وذلك حال دخول وقف اطلاق النار حيز
التنفيذ
ومن جانب اخر قال الرئيس الدائرات
السياسيه في حركه الجهاد الاسلاميه محمد
الهندي في مقابله مع الجزيره ان الحركه
ابلغت جميع الفصائل الفلسطينيه المنضويه
تحت لواء غرفه العمليات المشتركه بتفاصيل
اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار
[موسيقى]
الغرفه المشتركه وال
فضائل يعني ابلاغ مسبق لقبل الاعلان وكان
هناك موافقه
للتواصل الى هذا الاعلان الكل الكل تم
ابلاغهم في الغرفه المشتركه حماس في
البدايه وايضا
الفصائل المشاركه في الغرفه المشتركه
قبل ان نواصل ننوع الى هذا الخبر العاجل
مراسل الجزيره يقول ان الجيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي يقصف مرصدا للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه شرق مدينه غزه نعود لتصريحات
رئيس الدائره السياسيه في حركه الجهاد
الاسلاميه محمد الهندي الذي قال ان الضمان
الحقيقيه
لوقف اطلاق النار تبقى قوه ووحده الداخل
الفلسطيني والالتفاف حول خيار المقاومه
اسرائيل دائما يعني ان تتفلت ولا مهما
كانت الضمانات وغير الضمانات الضمانات هي
قوتنا ووحدتنا والان احنا حافظنا على
قوتنا وعلى وحدتنا الى اخر لحظه
وطالما هناك يعني وحده داخليه فلسطينيه
والكفاف على خيار المقاومه وطالما ان
المقاومه تراكم قوتها هذه الضمائر الوحيده
امامنا ونحن نتوقع كما حدث في السابق كما
تقول نتوقع عند اسرائيل ممكن ان ياتي يعني
لحظه وتدير ظهرها لاي اتفاق لكن على كل
حال هذا الاعلان
ايضا سوري في الاساس وبذل جهد كبير فيه
وموجود الان امام الجميع
وينضم الينا من غزه مراسل الجزيره هشام
زقوط هشام ضعنا في تفاصيل هذا القصف لمرصد
للمقاومه شرق قطاع غزه
زين العابدين المدفعيه الاسرائيليه اطلقت
عددا من القذائف باتجاه بعض المراصد
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه في شمال وجنوب قطاع
غزه بحسب شهود العيان والمصادر الامنيه
فان الجيش الاسرائيلي والمدفعيه
الاسرائيليه على حدود القطاع قصفت ثلاث
مناصب تتبع لهذه المقاومه الفلسطينيه على
هذه الحدود الشرقيه على طول قطاع غزه
بالتاكيد هذا يعتبر الخرق الاول لوقف
اطلاق لاتفاق وقف اطلاق النار الذي بدا
عند العاشره عند العاشره مساء امس
وبالتاكيد هذه حتى الان هذه المناصب
ومواقع التابعه للمقاومه الفلسطينيه هي
مراصد متقدمه قريبه جدا من الحدود مع قطاع
غزه الحدود الاسرائيليه مع قطاع غزه
وبالتالي لا تعتبر كسرا كبيرا لهذا
الاتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار لكنها بالتاكيد
خرقا لهذا الاتفاق
خلال الجانب الاسرائيلي عن اطلاق صواريخ
من قطاع غزه على مدن وبلدات غلاف غزه هل
تم تاكيد ذلك من الجانب الفصائل
الفلسطينيه
الفصائل الفلسطينيه صراحه زين العابدين لم
تعلن اي واي جهه من هذه الفصائل او فلسطين
وحتى الغرفه المشتركه لم تعلق على اطلاق
هذه الصواريخ
وبالتاكيد ستتضح الصوره خلال الساعات
القادمه ان كانت هناك اي خروقات لكن
بالتاكيد اطلاق هذه الصواريخ وايضا القصف
المدفعي الاسرائيلي على هذه المواقع تعتبر
خروج لهذه التهدئه ووقف اطلاق النار لكن
ليست خروقا كبيره يمكن ان تؤدي الى نسف
هذه التهدئه وهذا الاتفاق بكل تاكيد ورغم
كل ما جرى وهذه وهذا التصعيد البسيط ربما
ما زال الناس هنا في الشوارع يتواجدون لكن
انخفضت وتيره هذا التواجد بسبب هذه
الانباء عن القصف الاسرائيلي وايضا عن
اطلاق هذه الصواريخ خلال لكن مع ذلك لم
اعلنت اللجنه الرئاسيه للمعابر الفلسطينيه
ان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي سيفتح غدا المعابر
ونحن نتحدث عن معبرين اساسيين تسيطر عليهم
عليهما اسرائيل معبر كرم ابو سالم في جنوب
القطاع ومعبر ايرز بيت حانون في شمال
القطاع وبالتالي ستتدفق غدا
مواد التموينيه والاساسيه والوقود
والمستلزمات الصحيه الطبيه
للمستشفيات ايضا والوقود اللازم لمحطه
توليد الكهرباء التي كانت مهدده بالتوقف
في قطاع غزه بعد خمسه ايام من منع
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي هذا الوقود من الوصول
الى هذه المحطه والى والى مخازنها وايضا
معبر بيت حانون سيسمح غدا بمرور العمال
وايضا مرور المرضى وهم نحو 500 مريض ايضا
كانوا يتواجدون في قطاع غزه ولديهم مواعيد
مسبقه في مستشفيات الضفه الغربيه والداخل
المحتل ومدينه القدس وهم خصوصا
الاورام كما سيتم نقل عدد من الجرحى الذين
اصيبوا خلال هذه الموجه من التصعيد الى
تلك المستشفيات في ظل عدم توفر العلاج
اللازم لهم في مستشفيات غزه شكرا جزيلا لك
هشام زقوط من غزه ومعنى من تل ابيب احمد
هزيم مراسل للجزيره لينقل لنا الصوره من
تل ابيب على هذا القصف لاهداف شرق مدينه
غزه وايضا ما اعلن سابقا عن صفارات
الانذار وانطلاق صواريخ من قطاع غزه
نعم زين
بناء الموقف في تل ابيب الحكومه
الاسرائيليه كانت قد اصدرت بيامنا سترد
على اي خروقات لاتفاق وقف اطلاق النار
وربما المدفعيه الاسرائيليه التي استانفت
مواقع في غزه هو هذا الاسرائيلي الذي
ارادته في
كرد على عمليات اطلاق صواريخ لكن بالمجمل
زين
بالمجمل الحكومه الاسرائيليه تسعى الى سعه
على مدى الايام الماضيه الى هذه الى هذه
الهدنه الى هذا الاتفاق وهي من مصلحتها
حسب ما يرى كثير من المحللون هنا من انها
من مصلحتها ان يستمر او ان يثبت اتفاق وقف
اطلاق النار خصوصا وانها على طيله الايام
القليله الماضيه كانت تبعث بالرسائل اما
بالتسريب لوسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه او
بارسال الرسائل الى الفصائل الفصائل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه عبر الوسيط المصري من
ان التهدئه ستقابل بالتهدئه من ان وقف
العوده الى وقفه وقف
النار وما تريده اسرائيل وانها ستستمر في
قاراتها طالما استمر استمرت عمليات اطلاق
الصواريخ الان تم التوصل الى هذا الاتفاق
عبر الوسيط المصري هناك بيان يشكر الجهود
المصريه من قبل مكتب رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو وتترقب اسرائيل او ترقب الحكومه
الاسرائيليه كيف
سيتم الالتزام بهذا الاتفاق هل ستلتزم به
اسرائيل هذا ايضا محل سؤال محل تساؤل هناك
شعور
بالمجتمع الاسرائيلي يتنفس السعداء بعد
ايام قضاها في متعطله حياته اليوميه حياته
اليوميه تعطلت بالكامل المدينه تل ابيب
هذه التي عرض تكون مكتظه بعطه نهايه
الاسبوع كانت خاويه كل هذه المظاهر الان
باتت
باتت تعود تدريجيا الى حياتها الطبيعيه
هناك توجيه ارسل الى مستوطنات ومدن غلاف
غزه بان يخرج من الملاجئ لكن يبقوا قريبين
منها بانتظار ان يث بت هذا وقف اطلاق
النار هذا ويثبت هذا الاتفاق رغم هذه
الخروقات البسيطه زين شكرا جزيلا لك احمد
هزيم مراسل للجزيره من تل ابيب
تصمت النيران او هكذا يفترض فثم اتفاق
اخيرا لوقف اطلاق النار بين اسرائيل
والفصائل الفلسطينيه كان مصدر قد قال
للجزيره انه وسط التهدئه قدم صيغه جديده
لوقف متبادل لاطلاق النار في غزه واين
الصيغه الجديده تتضمن وقف استهداف
المدنيين وقصف منازلهم طالما ان المقاومه
تراكم قوتها هذه الضمانه الوحيده امامنا
الاتفاق لكن بغض الطرف عن التفاصيل فحديث
الساعه المحتوم عن التطبيق على الارض
يتساءل متابعون للمشهد الله منذ ايام عن
طرق تثبيت وقف اطلاق النار
ليس معروفا ايضا كيف سيتم التاكد من
التزام الجانبين بما ورد في نص اتفاقهما
وهل تمت اليه واضحه لذلك لا يبدو الامر
يسيرا بالنظر الى الفتره التي استغرقتها
جهود ومحاولات التوصل لتهدئه هل الامر
مختلف هذه المره قد لا يتوافق هذا التوجه
مع نهج التصعيد العسكري الذي اطلقه
الاحتلال في قطاع غزه دون مبرر الامني
مباشر بل مع تلويحه المستمر كذلك بنقل
المواجهه الى مستويات اخرى لكن ابرام
اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار لا يمكن فصله عن
المشهد السياسي والامني في الداخل
الاسرائيلي
ضغوط مورست لا شك على ائتلاف نتنياهو
اليميني كي يضع حدا لما بدا في البدء حتى
في نظر المعارضه الاسرائيليه عمليه صحيحه
وناجحه لكنها ابانت مع الوقت عن كلف باهظه
لا احد في اسرائيل مستعد كما يبدو
للاستمرار في دفعها ربما كانت الصعيد في
غزه واستئناف عمليات اغتيال قاده المقاومه
رضوحا لعتاه المتطرفين في حكومته بما يحفظ
تماسكها وربما ساعه حقا لترميم قوه ردع
اسرائيل الاخذه في التاكل لكن محللين في
اسرائيل يرجحون الا تكون مكاسب نتنياهو من
خطوته على قدر توقعاته فلا يبرا من كل
متاعبه الداخليه من خلال تغريب الاجنده
الامنيه وتصدير ازماته الداخليه بل تجده
في المقابل مدفوعا من النخب السياسيه
والاعلاميه وحتى من الشارع لانهاء التصعيد
العسكري
ستجد الاكثر نقبه المتاثرين في مستوطنات
غلاف غزه من رد المقاومه القوي والمنسق
وكذا المستشعرين للاعباء الاقتصاديه
المتولده عن التصعيد ولخسائر اخرى اكبر قد
يتكبدونها اذا طالت المواجهه او اتسعت
رقعتها حكومه نتنياهو الائتلافيه احرص من
هؤلاء جميعا كما يبدو على ثلاث حرب من ذلك
القبيل
من غزه الدكتور ايمن الرفاتي الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي اذا انتهت جوله التصعيد
رغم ما يقال عن صواريخ من هنا او قصف
مدفعي من هناك لكن انتهت متى حققت هذه
الجوله للجانب الفلسطيني
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم يعني حققت هذه
الجوله الكثير من يعني النقاط المهمه
للقضيه الفلسطينيه وللمقاومه الفلسطينيه
خاصه على قضيه وحده الموقف في الميدان وفي
الجانب السياسي حيث
ظهر ذلك جليا من خلال غرفه عمليات الغرفه
المشتركه لعمليات المقاومه التي قدمت
نموذجا مشرفا للشعب الفلسطيني واعطت صوره
واضحه على طريقه التعامل المستقبلي
الفصائل فيما بينها وفي الميدان وهذا يفسد
يعني مخططات اسرائيليه والسياسه
الاسرائيليه التي كانت طيله السنوات
الماضيه والعقود الماضيه التي تقوم على
مبدا التفرقه ومبدا الاستفراد بفصيل معين
او جبهه معينه بهذه الوحده وبهذه الغرفه
المشتركه لفصائل المقاومه يعني افشلت
المقاومه محاولات استفراد الاحتلال بفصيل
معين وايضا اعطت الفصائل الف درسا هاما
بانهم حينما يكونوا على قلبي رجل واحد
يمكنهم ان يدفعوا هذا الاحتلال للرضوخ
ويمكنهم ان يحققوا انجازات ويفرضوا الشروط
التي يريدونها ويدفع الاقليم ويدفعوا
المجتمع الدولي والاداره الامريكيه للتدخل
يعني تحقيق الشروط التي يريدونها بالاضافه
الى ان هذه الجوله حققت يعني اعطت
الفلسطينيين صوره واضحه عن طبيعه هذا
الاحتلال الذي بدا واضحا عجزه في طريقه
التعامل مع المقاومه خاصه انه لم يعد
قادرا على فرض واعاده ترميم صوره الردع
التي كان يتغنى بها سابقا هذا من ناحيه
ومن ناحيه ثانيه منعت المقاومه الفلسطينيه
رئيس الوزراء في دوله الاحتلال بنيامين
نتنياهو من تمرير مخططه الذي كان يريد من
خلاله نقل الازمه الداخليه وتصدير الازمه
الداخليه من المجتمع الصهيوني الى قطاع
غزه ومحاوله الحصول على نقاط قوه له في
الانتخابات المقبله وبالتالي نتنياهو
اليوم خرج من هذه المعركه خالي الوفاض بل
ينتظروا الكثير من الانتقادات في المجتمع
الاسرائيلي خاصه ان المعارضه وهنالك
الكثير من المحللين اشاروا الى ان هذه
الجوله كان لها او كان يجب ان تنتهي قبل
يومين وبالتالي نتنياهو يتحمل مسؤوليه
اطاله امد هذه المعركه بالاضافه الى ان
نتنياهو
ظهر في هذه المعركه غير قادر على التعاطي
مع المتغيرات والتهديدات الامنيه المحيطه
بدوله الاحتلال وخاصه من جبهه قطاع غزه
التي خرجت منها قطاع غزه بذات القوه التي
دخلت فيها المقاومه اليوم متوحده المقاومه
استخدمت وتيره
متناسبه من النيران دفعت الاحتلال يعني
كبلت الاحتلال في ردوده تجاه قطاع غزه
وجعلته خائفا من ان تزيد من مدايات
الصواريخ ومن كثافه النيران التي تستخدم
في هذه المعركه وهذا ربما يعد احد اهم
النقاط التي كانت نتيجه الغرفه المشتركه
لفصائل المقاومه التي وفرت الدعم اللوجستي
والتي وفرت المعلومات الاستخباريه واداره
النار واداره طريقه التعامل مع هذا
الاحتلال وجعلت المنظومه الامنيه في دوله
الاحتلال ومن يقدرون الموقف في لدى
الحكومه في دوله الاحتلال في حيره من
امرهم خاصه انها استخدم التكتيكات جديده
منها تكتيكات الصمت في بدايه المعركه
وايضا تكتيكات استخدام النار
والتحكم بمدايات القصف والضغط على الجبهه
الداخليه في دوله الاحتلال وتحيل الفرص
التي تؤثر على المستوى السياسي وتؤثر على
بنيامين نتنياهو هذا يعني هذه الجوله ربما
تكون بروفا
لجولات كبيره او معركه كبيره قادمه بين
المقاومه سواء في الفتره القريبه او في
الفتره البعيده في الرفاه الكاتب المحلل
السياسي من غزه شكرا جزيلا لك وينضم الينا
من النصر الدكتور محمود يسبك استاذ دراسات
الشرق الاوسط في جامعه حيفا يعني من اليوم
الاول
لهذه الجوله قال وزير الدفاع
انها حققت اهدافها باغتيال القيادات
الثلاثه في الجهاد الاسلامي بعد خمسه ايام
من انتهاء من هذه الجوله وبعد استشهاد
ثلاثه وثلاثين فلسطينيا
في هذه الجوله كثير منهم من الاطفال
والنساء قلب بالفعل حققت هذه الجوله
اهدافها بالنسبه لاسرائيل
انا اعتقد انه هذه الجوله لم تحقق شيء
لاسرائيل من ناحيه الاهداف الموضوعه على
العكس اسرائيل يعني
فشرت فشلا درعا منذ اللحظه الاولى حقيقه
استطاعت وهذا يعني كان متوقع تستطيع ان
تفعله دائما قتل بدم بارد الثلاث القيادات
الثلاثه الجهاد الاسلامي هو اطفالهم
وعائلاتهم ونسائهم ولكن هذا القتل هذه
المره ورد الفعل الفلسطيني 38 ساعه من
الصمت اعطى فرصه للاعلام العالمي بيظهر
صور الاطفال الذين تم قتلهم بدم بارد هذا
اول شيء مما احرج اسرائيل احرجا كبيرا جدا
اثنين الهدف الاسرائيلي منذ البدايه ان
كان رئيس الحكومه نتنياهو او وزير الامن
او حتى الاحزاب اليمينيه الاخرى التي
تشارك بالحكومه اظهار وكانه اسرائيل هي
قوه عليا لا يستطيع احد مقاومتها وجاء
الرد الفلسطيني بعد هذا الهدوء والصمت
الذي كسر عمليا الصمت في البدايه 38 ساعه
كسرت النفسيه الاسرائيليه وهذا شيء هام
جدا يعني من يعرف كيف تصرف سكان غلاف غزه
بخوف شديد ولا يعرف ماذا يحدث هل ستقوم
المقاومه بالرد ام انه المقاومه عمليا
يعني انتهت هنالك بعض المحللين
الاسرائيليين الذين اعتقدوا انهم من
الضربه الاولى بطل في مقاول تعز المقاومه
وحينما بدا وجاء الرد كنت ترى هذه الجموع
الاسرائيليه كيف تهجر بيوتها وتهجر
اماكنها يعني اكتظار كبير في الشوارع
للهروب الى شمال البلاد هذا يعني الضغط
ولذلك نحن راينا منذ هذه اللحظه ما الذي
فاجا الاسرائيليين الذي فاجعهم الصمت
الفلسطيني نعم اولا الصمت الفلسطيني خلال
38 ساعه هذا لم يكن كانت اسرائيل تعتقد
بانه بعد مقتل هؤلاء القاده سيقوم ستقوم
الجهاز الاسلامي او غيره بالرد المباشر
ولم يكن هنالك ردا مباشر هذا فاجاه مفاجاه
كبيره جدا وبعد ذلك كل الضربات الفلسطينيه
حينما كانت ترد على الغارات الاسرائيليه
كانت محسوبه حسابا دقيقا وهذا ما نفهمه من
عمليه غرفه العمليات المشتركه لم يكن هذه
المره اي ضربات عشوائيه من الجهه
الفلسطينيه كل ضربه كانت محسوبه اين تصل
وكيف تصل ومن مداها وكيف وكيف تؤثر
بالمجتمع الاسرائيلي وهذا طبعا له مردود
سياسي بالنسبه لاسرائيل هذا المردود
السياسي هو اضعاف موقف نتنياهو اكثر واكثر
وحتى انه بنكفير نفسه وحزب بن جبير الذي
كان ينادي
باغراق غزه وانهاء غزه واحتلال غزه هذا
الان يعني يصدر بيان قبل
حوالي نصف ساعه يعني فيه الانهزاميه هذه
الانهزاميه التي بدات تظهر وخاصه كذلك لدى
رؤساء سلطات محليه في الكره المجاوره لغزه
الكره الاسرائيليه مجاور غزه هذه الاصوات
بدات تتعالى ومما يضعف موقف نتنياهو
والحكومه الاسرائيليه وهذا يمكن وماذا
تستطيع الحكم الاسرائيليه تفعل الى اي مدى
يمكن استثمار ما جرى يعني هل هل سينجح
بترياهه وحكومته وحلفاؤه من اليمين
المتطرف في استثمار متجر باي شكل من
الاشكال
على العكس انا اعتقد انه الان من
سيستثمر هو المتظاهرين الذين يتظاهرون ضد
نتنياهو وبدات اصوات هؤلاء يعني لاول مره
نحن راينا مظاهرات من اليهود في شوارع
اسرائيل في اماكن مختلفه ترفع يافطات خلال
المعركه خلال
الضربات
باتهام حكومه اسرائيل بانها تقوم بعمل
سياسي وليس عمل عسكري باستغلال القضيه
العسكريه استغلالا سياسيا هذا لم يحدث في
مرات سابقه في المجتمع الاسرائيلي معنى
ذلك انه الجبهه الداخليه الاسرائيليه يعني
موجوده الان في ضغط كبير جدا ضغط سياسي
كبير جدا وهذا الضغط ينتقل مباشره في
الايام القادمه باعتقاد ثلاث مع ذلك
بتفاصيل كثيره كيف سينتقل هذا على الى
الحكومه الاسرائيليه نفسها هذا يعني يؤدي
الى فشل نتنياهو وانا اعتقد هذا هو
المسمار الاول في نعش الحكومه الاسرائيليه
والتقريب الانتخابات في يعني لمده اكثر من
مكان متوقع شكرا جزيلا لك من
الناصره الدكتور محمود
الشرق الاوسط في جامعه حيفا
الضمرين من رام الله الدكتور هاني المصري
مدير مركز مسارات لابحاث السياسات ودراسات
الاستراتيجيه خمسه ايام من التصعيد
والمتواصل الاسرائيلي والرد المتصاعد من
المقاومه الفلسطينيه انتهت الليله قبل
اكثر من ساعتين 25 دقيقه من الان
فماذا يمكن الخروج به من هذه الجوله وانت
كمحلل سياسي في رام الله
اهم انجاز ان العدوان وقف
والجهاد الاسلامي الذي قام بدور رئيسي
وراس الحربه في هذه المواجهه لا يزال
صامدا ومقاوما وقادر على اطلاق الصواريخ
حتى ما بعد الاعلان عن بدء وقت اطلاق
النار هذا انجاز بحد ذاته لان هو فقط ننوه
لانه الجهاد لم يعلن مسؤوليته عن ما تقول
اسرائيل انه صواريخ اطلقت من غزه بعد
الهدنه حتى هذه اللحظه يعني نعم ولكن هناك
صواريخ بغض النظر عن من اطلقها اشاره انه
لا يزال الطرف الفلسطيني قادرا لم يتم كسر
ارادته لم يتم القضاء عليه وهذا شيء مهم
جدا ولكن ايضا علينا ان نرى ان وقف
العدوان انجاز لانه لا يمكن يعني نتنياهو
من تحقيق اهداف قد حققها اثناء العدوان
اول هدف حققه نتنياهو انه استطاع ان يجعل
الحكومه والمعارضه وراءه لانهم كلهم ضد
الفلسطينيين ويريدون الاقتصاص من
الفلسطينيين وهذا ادى الى رفع شعبيه
نتنياهو لذلك كان من المهم وقف العدوان
حتى تعود الامور الى طبيعتها وحتى مفاعيل
الازمه الداخليه في اسرائيل وهي ازمه
بنيويه عميقه تاخذ مداها وهذا سيؤثر على
دور اسرائيل سواء ازاء الفلسطينيين او
دورها الاقلام الاقليمي او العالمي مساله
ثالثه رغم الوحده التي تجلت في هذه الجوله
ولكن لا يجب ان نخفي ان هذه الوحده تخفي
خلافات الا انه ليس من المعقول ان يقوم
الجهاد الاسلامي للمره الثالثه او الرابعه
بخوض المعركه لوحده توفير غطاء السياسي
كما قال الدكتور محمد الهندي لا يعني
المشاركه المشتركه في هذه
المواجهه وهذا يعني ان هناك تباينات وان
هناك اولويات وان هناك مشاريع سياسيه
مختلفه مما يستدعي من اهم ولماذا نقول ان
هناك
وتفاهمات وتقدير موحد للازمه
وللخطر لان هذا الشيء غير منسجم مع المنطق
وسمعنا محمد الهندي على قناتكم وهو يقول
ان الغرفه المشتركه وفرت الغطاء وان الذي
فاوضه والجهاد ان الذي قدم الدم هو الجهاد
ان الذي اطلق الصواريخ هو الجهاد وهذا له
اعتبارات انا لا اقول انه ليس له اعتبارات
هذا يستدعي الحوار يستدعي الاتفاق لان
حركه حماس وهي العمود الرئيسي للمقاومه
لها مشروع سياسي ولها نظره على سبيل
المثال يمكن ان تكون حماس ليست موافقه على
التوقيت
السياسي لهذه المعركه لان ان يكون يعني
استشهاد قائد ورمز كبير عنوان لهذه
المواجهه ليس امس امس طريقه للمواجهه كان
يمكن ان تكون القدس او او اسرى
يمكن مثلما حدث في معركه سيف القدس كما
تذكر في عام 2021 حيث كانت المواجهه
والهبه شامله والتضامن واسع جدا يعني هذه
المسائل الضفه الغربيه بصراحه حتى
دكتور هادي ماذا عن الضفه الغربيه ماذا عن
السلطه الفلسطينيه ما الذي يمكن ان تخرج
به من هذه الجوله ما الدروس التي يمكن
تعلمها من هذه الجوله
للاسف السلطه الفلسطينيه والقياده الرسميه
الفلسطينيه كانت ليست ذات الصله وليست
طرفا وهذا ما صرح به يعني عزام الاحمد في
احد المقابلات بكل صراحه في حين اننا في
العدوان عام 2014 كان هناك وقت فلسطيني
موحد وكان رئيسه عزام الاحمد اذا السلطه
الفلسطينيه ببؤس سياستها
بارتباطها مع منظومه الامن الاسرائيليه من
خلال استمرار التنسيق الامني والالتزامات
المترتبه على اتفاق اوسلو جعلت نفسها كان
هذه المعركه ليست معركتها وبالتالي لم
تلعب دورا لا بالمعركه ولا بالمفاوضات ولا
بالنتائج وهذا ايضا احد الدروس الكبيره
الى متى سيستمر الانقسام الفلسطيني هذا
الانقسام المدمر ليس لطرف فلسطيني لوحده
هذا الانقسام هو الذي يمنع الوحده الوطنيه
والمؤسسه الوطنيه الجامعه والاستراتيجيه
الواحده وهذا الامر من اهم الدروس التي
يجب ان ناخذها وحتى نستطيع ان نستعد
للجولات القادمه لانه سيكون هناك بالتاكيد
جولات قادمه لاننا في حرب مفتوح حتى تحقيق
اهداف شكرا الشعب الفلسطيني شكرا دكتور
هذه المصري مدير مركز مسارات
لابحاث السياسات والدراسات الاستراتيجيه
وايضا مرينا من كاليف
المقرر الخاص السابق للامم المتحده لحقوق
الانسان في الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله
وانت تتابع هذا الهجوم الاسرائيلي المستمر
بالطائرات الحربيه وبالمدافع وبالمسيرات
على منازل المدنيين لتقتل الاطفال والنساء
اي مكان الهدف كيف تنظر الى ما جرى بعد
انتهائه الان بعد خمسه ايام من جولات
التصعيد
اعتقد علينا ان ننظر للسياقه الاوسع لما
يحدث في اسرائيل
منذ وصول حكومه ان تنياهو في المرحله
الماضيه اعتقد اننا شهدنا الكثير من
التحولات والكثير من الوقائع لا في الضفه
الغربيه وايضا في غزه
واعتقد
ان
اسرائيل في هذه المرحله حاولت ان تظهر
قوتها ضد الفلسطينيين لكن هذا طبعا
ادى الى استعار ايضا المقاومه الفلسطينيه
التي صمدت في وجه اسرائيل
وراينا مجموعه من جولات المواجهه
واستمرار لاتون العنف في المنطقه والفعل
ورده الفعل
وشاهدنا ما حصل في غزه في المرحله الماضيه
اذا علينا ان نفهم هذا السياق الاعمى وهذا
السياق
اوسع لما يحدث في المنطقه يجب ان نقول بان
هناك
خرق سافر
للقانون الدولي من قبل اسرائيل واعتقد ان
هناك مجموعه من
القرارات التي ضرب بها عرض الحائط ولم يكن
هناك اي احترام لحقوق الشعب الفلسطيني
خاصه محمد وعلى اله شكرا جزيلا شكرا
شكرا جزيلا لك
سد ريتشارد فوق وننتقل الى هذه الكلمه الى
الامين العام لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي زياد
النخاله
في الصراع مع المشروع الصهيوني
معركه ثار الاحرار
جوله
فقدنا فيها اعز ابنائنا من القاده الشهداء
الذين كانوا بحضورهم
قيمه كبرى لحركه الجهاد
ولسراياها الباسله
وستبقى شهادتهم
نورا يضيء طريق جهادنا
وفقدنا العديد من ابناء شعبنا الاعزاء
الذين قتلتهم اله العدو الصهيوني
نودعهم جميعا بفخر واعتزاز
وان شعبا فيه امثال القاده الكبار
قاده سرايا القدس
الذين ارتقوا شهداء
وقدموا اعز ما يملكون من ابنائهم
وارواحهم
لن يهزم ابدا
[موسيقى]
وسيبقى رافعا
رايه القدس
ومجاهدا لتحريرها
مهما طال الزمن ان شاء الله
لقد ارادوا ان يغرقونا بدمائنا
ودماء اخواننا وعائلاتهم واطفالهم
وارادوا ان نبتلع دماءهم ونصمت
ونشتري حياتنا بالذل والقهر ارادوا ان
نكمل حياتنا بطريقتهم
وتحت نعال جنودهم
فخرج لهم مجاهدوا شعبنا
الفلسطيني شجاع من سرايا القدس
يرفضون ابتلاع الدم
وقدم شعبنا شهداء وخسائر ماديه كبيره
ولكن الموقف كان يستحق ذلك واكثر
وكان يجب ان تكون رساله شعبنا
كما كانت عليه في الايام الخمسه الماضيه
فكانت كل مدنهم تحت مرمى صواريخ سرايا
القدس والمقاومه الفلسطينيه
وجميعكم
شاهد جموعهم وهي تختبئ في الملاجئ
وتختبئ تحت محطات الباصات هلا عن ورعبا
وشعبنا رغم الالم يخرج مرفوع الراس
في كل مكان في غزه والضفه
وعلى امتداد العالم
مؤيدا ومساندا
وان مشاهد التضامن الفلسطيني عندما تستهدف
بيوت المدنيين
وهم يدافعون وهم يتدافعون لتقديم العون
والمساعده
لمن تقصف بيوتهم
له مسار فخر وعز
ودرس لامتنا
انها ايام عز وكرامه لشعبنا الذي يواجه
بالامكانيات البسيطه كل هذا العدوان
المدجج بكل ادوات الموت والدمار
وصمد شعبنا ولم ينكسر ولن ينكسر
وحافظنا رغم كل الظروف الصعبه
والمعقده على وحده شعبنا ومقاومته
نعم
كانت سرايا القدس المظفره
ومقاتلوها الابطال
في هذه المعركه راس حربه راس حربه
المقاومه وعنوانها
ولكن
كانت المقاومه بكل فصائلها
جدارا قويا
تستند اليه
مقاومه مقاتلين
وفوتنا الفرصه على العدو
ان يفرقنا
وتحملنا ما تحملنا من اجل ان يبقى الموقف
موحدا وقويا
وها نحن نخرج من هذه المعركه
وسلاحنا بايدينا
ومقاتلون ما زالوا في الميدان جاهزين
على مدار الوقت
[موسيقى]
لمقارعه اي عدوان
وبهذه المناسبه اتقدم بالشكر الكبير
لكل الذين وقفوا بجانبنا
مؤيدين او مساندين وداعمين
وعلى راسهم الجمهوريه الاسلاميه في ايران
والاخوه في حزب الله
والاخوه في جمهوريه مصر العربيه الذين
بذلوا جهودا كبيره في كبح العدوان وكذلك
الاخوه في دوله قطر
العزيزه وكل الذين اتصلوا بنا للتعبير عن
تضامنهم مع شعبنا ومقاومته وكذلك كافه
الفضائيات الذين غطت جهاد شعبنا ومقاومته
ضد العدوان وباذن الله تعالى
لنا لقاء اخر
لنكرم شهداء معركه ثار الاحرار جميعا
المجد للشهداء
المجد لشهداء معركه فار الاحرار
المجد لشهداء شعبنا
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
يستعد اكثر من 60 مليون من الناخبين
الاتراك للتوجه الى صناديق الاقتراع صباح
اليوم الاحد لانتخاب رئيس جديد للبلاد
يعبروا بالجمهوريه نحو مئويتها الثانيه
بالاضافه الى 600 نائب يشكلون البرلمان
الجديد ومنذ الساعه السادسه من مساء امس
بالتوقيت المحلي دخلت تركيا مرحله الصمت
الانتخابي بشكل رسمي حيث تم حظر الدعايه
الانتخابيه بكل اشكالها يتنفس على منصب
الرئاسه الرئيس التركي ومرشح تحالف
الجمهور رجب طيب اردوغان الذي يطمح للفوز
بولايه ثانيه واخيره بعد تحول البلاد الى
النظام الرئاسي كما ينافسه مرشح تحالف
الشعب وزعيم حزب الشعب الجمهوري كمال
كريجدار اوغلو ومرشح وتحالف الاجداد سنان
وجان وكان مرشح حزب البلد محرم انجا قد
انقرر الانسحاب يوم امس الجمعه من السباق
الرئاسي ويتنفس اربعه وعشرون ح سياسيا على
المقاعد ال600 المماثله في البرلمان
حمله انتخابيه ماراثونيه تلك التي يقودها
الرئيس اردوغان قبيل انتخابات رئاسيه
وبرلمانيه توصف بانها الاصعب في تاريخ
حزبه
حمله تركز بشكل كبير على وعود باعاده بناء
المدن التي ضربها زلزال كهرمان مراش
وبمرحلتين من التنميه المستدامه والانتعاش
الاقتصادي نحلم بمئويه تركيا ويحلمون
بتركيا المهمشه القديمه بالسياستها
المجزئه واقتصادها الهش
وديمقراطيتها الضعيفه
في شوارع المدن التركيه تنتشر كوادر حزب
العداله والتنميه ومرشحوه للبرلمان لشرح
البرامج المستقبليه وتذكير الناس
بالمشاريع الضخمه التي انجزها الحزب ليس
لدينا شك في اننا سنفوز الشعب يعرف ما
الذي قدمه الرئيس لهذه الامه خلال 21 عاما
لكن المعارضه تقول انها ستفوز لانكم
تتحدثون عن المشاريع العملاقه بينما الناس
يعانون من الغلاء
هناك ازمه اقتصاديه لكنها عالميه
واقتصادنا يعمل بكفاءه وهذا سينعكس على
المواطن قريبا المواطنين يعرفون ان
اردوغان وحده هو الذي يمكنه تجاوز هذه
الازمه
هنا اجواء الحمله الانتخابيه سخونه فهي
تنظر الى هذه الانتخابات على انها فرصه
تاريخيه للفوز
زعيم وحزب الشعب الجمهوري يخوض المنافسه
ضمن تحالف واسع الماني يساري وقوميا
ومحافظ ويعد بتغيير ما يصفه بحكم الفرد
وبانقاد البلاد من الازمه الاقتصاديه
هذه هي الانتخابات التي سيعاد فيها بناء
الديمقراطيه وبناء تركيا التي لن ينام
فيها طفل وهو جائع
رافقنا اوز المرشح للبرلمان الحزب الشعبي
الجمهوري في جولته اليوميه على المحال
التجاريه في مختلف مناطق اسطنبول
نشرح للتجار حقيقه الوضع الاقتصادي ونتحدث
لهم عن خطه حزبنا لانقاذ البلاد
اكبروكم وعلى ماذا تعتمدون بالاساس للخروج
من الازمه
التجار مهم
وم تحدثوننا عن ارتفاع الاسعار وانخفاض
القدره بالاساس تعتمد على التشاركيه في
الحكم
وبعد انسحاب محرم ان جميع السباق
الانتخابي وهو المحسوب على اليسار التركي
بقي سنانو عن القومي الذي يركز برنامجه
الانتخابي بشكل اساسي على ضروره اعاده
اللاجئين الى بلادهم
ربما كثير من الناس مقتنعون بالرجلين لكن
معظمهم لن يصوتوا لهما لاعتقادهم ان
اصواتهم ستذهب سدى في ظل التنافس الكبير
بين تحالفي الشعب والجمهور كل حي او شارع
في تركيا قد يكونوا ساحه للتنافس الحاد
على استقطاب المواطنين قبيله اقتراع يوصف
بانه الاكثر تعقيدا في تاريخ بلدهم طالما
صاحبه المنافسه السياسيه بين احزابه حاله
من الاستقطاب الشديد والمزمن
عمرنا في الجزيره اسطنبول
ويشكل الاقتصاد احد ابرز الملفات
الانتخابيه التي تشهدها تركيا في الرابع
عشر من مايو ايار المقبل حيث يزيد ما
يحالف الواقع حيث يزيد التضخم من اعبائي
وتكاليف المعيشه وتشير بعض استطلاعات
الراي لان كثيرا من الناخبين سيحددون
خيرهم الانتخابي وفق البرامج الاقتصاديه
للاحزاب والمرشحين
[موسيقى]
يعود مصطفى من عمله حاملا بعد احتياجات
المنزل الغذائيه تقاعد مصطفى منذ شهور
لكنه اضطر للعوده الى العمل مع ارتفاع
كلفه المعيشه
عائدات مصطفى الماليه ليست هزيله مقارنه
مع ملايين المواطنين الاتراك العاملين
بالحد الادنى للاجور
التضخم كارثه رغم معاش التقاعدي وراتب
الذي يتقاضاه من عمل الجديد فان الحصول
على الاساسيات لم يعد سهلا الذهاب في عطله
بات امرا صعبا صوتنا سيكون لمن لديه خطط
حقيقيه لخفض التضخم
تجرى الانتخابات المقبله بالتزامن مع موجه
غلاء فاحش تعاني منها البلاد جراء التضخم
واستمرار انخفاض قيمه الليره التركيه امام
العملات الرئيسيه
يدرك حزب العداله والتنميه الحاكم حجم
الخطر الذي يشكله ملفه الاقتصاد على فرص
الرئيس بالفوز في الانتخابات لذلك ركز في
اطلاق حملته الانتخابيه على اعلان برنامج
انتخابي مليء بالوعود الاقتصاديه
لا يمكن التغاضي عما قام به حزبنا في
العقدين الماضيين مشكلتنا الوحيده هي
التضخم نسعى الى خفضه على مراحل وعبر
سياسه اقتصاديه تعتمد زياده الانتاج
والمعروض في قطاعات الغذاء والعقارات
والطاقه
تركز المعارضه في حملاتها على الاقتصاد
ايضا اذ تعتبر التضخم من ابرز النتائج
السيئه لاداره الرئيس الاقتصاديه واحد اهم
الابواب التي قد تقودها الى الحكم
نتفقد المحاله التجاريه وما نسمعه من
مواطنين هو الشكوى نتيجه انخفاض القدره
الشرائيه جراء تضخم سنواجه ذلك عبر وقف
العصابات المتحكمه باقتصادنا وتشكيل اداره
تعتمد النظم الاقتصاديه الواقعيه
يعد الملف الاقتصادي هو مكافحه التضخم
ركيزه اساسيه
في اعاده هو رزقه ولقمه عيشه ما قد يلعب
دورا حاسما في تحديد هويه الفائز
بالانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه المقبله
المعتز بلا حسن الجزيره انقره
الا ان التطورات في السودان
مع الشبكات باسلحه ثقيله في الخرطوم بحري
وام درمان قال مصدران دبلوماسي سوداني
واخر في قوه الدعم السريع للجزيره ان
المرحله الثانيه للمفاوضات بين الجيش
السوداني وقوه الدعم السريع ستبدا اليوم
الاحد في مدينه جده السعوديه بواسطه
امريكيه سعوديه وبحسب المصدرين ستتناول
هذه الجوله من المفاوضات تفاصيل هدنه
جديده بين الطرفين من ناحيه المده الزمنيه
وتحديد الممرات الامنه للمدنيين الخاليه
من الوجود العسكري من الطرفين
وتناقش هذه الجوله ايضا تفاصيل اخلاء
القوات العسكريه للمشافي والمرافق
الحكوميه الخدميه واضاف المصدران ان جوله
الثالثه ستبدا بعد التاكد من التزام
الطرفين بالهدنه وستناقش وقفا العدائيات
ووقف اطلاق النار الدائم واشار المصدر
الدبلوماسي الى ان الرقابه على وقف اطلاق
النار الدائم ستتم عبر الاقمار الاصطناعيه
من الدول الراعيه للمفاوضات دون ان يستبعد
امكانيه وجود مراقبين على الارض من قبل
الاتحاد الافريقي
وفي ذات السياق قال مصدر حكومي انما وصفه
بالقوات المتمرده ترفض اخلاء المرافق
الحكوميه وتطالب بالسماح لها بالوجود في
معسكراتها التي كانت تستخدمها قبيلا دلاع
القتال الخامس عشر من ابريل نيسان الماضي
الامر الذي رفضه الجيش سابقا بحسب المصدر
الحكومي وسيرفضه مجددا في مفاوضات جدا لكن
مصدرا مطلعا في قوات الدعم السريعه اعتبر
ان الحديث عن العوده للمعسكرات من عدمها
سابق لاوانه نسيمه في ظل سيطره قواتهم على
70% من العاصمه الخرطوم وفقا لقوله
في الاثناء وصلت لمطاري بورتسودان بولايه
البحر الاحمر الشرقيه السودان طائره
ومساعده انسانيه قطريه حملت اكثر من سبعين
طنا من المواد الطبيه وقد اجلت الطائره
طائره الاغاثه لدى عودتها الى الدوحه نحو
270 شخصا من السودانيين العالقين من حمله
الاقامه القطريه مراسلنا حمد البكاري راكب
الرحله ووفانا بالتفاصيل
تتواصلوا عمليه تقديم مساعدات انسانيه
قطريه الى السودان وذلك عبر الجسر الجوي
الذي يربط بين الدوحه وبورد سودان هذه
الطائره التي كنا فيها كانت محمله باكثر
من 70 طنا من المواد الطبيه والادويه
والمستلزمات الطبيه وخصصت للجانب الطبي
نظمت عمليه الاغاثه من قبل مؤسسه قطر
الخيريه والهلال الاحمر القطري وكذلك
بالتنسيق مع الصليب الاحمر الدولي وكذلك
الهلال الاحمر السوداني بهدف الوصول الى
محتاجين ومتضررين نتيجه للحرب الدائره في
السودان هذه الرحله لم تكن الاولى وانما
هي امتداد لرحلات سابقه وبحسب القائمين
على تنظيم وتسيير مثل هذه الرحلات فان
هناك ايضا رحلات ستكون اخرى وقد لاحظنا من
خلال رصدنا
لتحرك هذه الرحلات بان هناك خدمه اخرى
تقدمها هذه الطائرات وهي عندما تعود الى
الدوحه فانها تقوم باجلاء عدد من
السودانيين المقيمين في قطر
وفي تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا قال
افقيني بريجوجن ملك شركه
تقدمت في مدينه بخموت بخمس مئه متر ولم
يبقى تحت سيطره الاوكرانيين متر ونصف
واضاف ان قواته سدت الفراغ الذي خلفه
تراجع القوات الروسيه في الجراحه الشمري
للمدينه ومن جهه الثانيه اكلت نائبته وزير
الدفاع الاوكرانيه انا مليار ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تتقدم وتدريجيا في اتجاهين من
ضواحي باخموت واوضحت ان الجيش الاوكرانيه
يواصل تدمير القوات الروسيه وقد تمكن من
اسر العديد من المقاتلين وفق قولها اعتبرت
مليارا ان القوات الروسيه اضحت عاجزه على
السيطره على مدينه باخموت مشيره الى انه
من الصعب ان تحسب المساحات التي استطاعت
القوات الاوكرانيه تحقيق تقدم فيها بدقه
نظرا لتواصل العمليات القتاليه
هذا ونقلت مواقع عسكريه روسيه ان سلاح
الجو الروسي قصفا مستودعا للذخيره في
منطقه
اوكرانيا وقالت تلك المواقع ان الضربه
تستهدف الذخيره لسلاح الجو الاوكراني في
المدينه ونشرت المواقع والصور الانفجار
المستودع والانفجار الاخر في مدينه
تيرنوبل اوكرانيا
بهذا مشاهدينا نصل الى ختام هذه الجوله
جوله الحصاد في امان الله
[موسيقى]